all right i think we are live
raghav we are live
we're live let's go i love this i'm very
excited hold on one second i'm just
gonna do one little thing
um all right everybody thank you so much
for being here we've been uh hyping this
up oh actually you know what i want to
do one other thing
now um oh no one second brother
um
where is that url that you gave me right
here the forms are up
uh
dustin let's put the form up there we go
with that garyvee book perfect that's
good
one thing i wanted to do was go into
discord
okay let's do that
and this
and it's just the friends it is
one second all right boom
i believe we are now very ready
to rock okay
well god why don't you tell everybody
who you are
yeah and dustin i'm sorry before that
dustin please put up the form everybody
who's on
let me kick this off before i go oh you
got a haircut you decided to look good
for this i know i actually i see it i
see you flex it fade
i see the [ __ ] fade um
everybody on instagram what's good
everybody on all the live channels
what's good very special day here right
now
uh if you go to garyvee.com
book i'm here to announce
my new book and a very special offer i
am going um i am going live with this
book on november 16th
and if you go to garyvee.com book
you will see that there is a form there
is that right rob
yep that's right because i haven't even
i haven't even looked at the blog post
i'm so busy today all the way to the
bottom they'll see the form at the
bottom let me give you the punch line
now and i see a lot of you in
the chat so here's the 4-1-1
if you buy 12 of these books
on amazon or barnes noble's website
right now by the way rogov can you look
up the rank on amazon and barnes noble
right now the overall rank of my book
if you buy 12 books
if you go to garyvee.com
if you buy 12 books
uh and for every 12 books there's a form
to fill out where you upload your
receipt so every 12 book off order
counts as one of a surprise that i'm
going to do for you on november 16th now
this surprise for every 12 books that
you buy looks like this
if you've been paying attention to me
for the last nine months you will
realize that
i'm very hot on a subject matter
it is my belief
that if you buy 12 of these or 60 if you
want five of them or 600 if you want 50
of them
that for every 12 book order you buy you
will be getting one of these let's call
it airdropped
if you've been paying attention the
amount of fomo you probably have this
the amount of fomo of people that did
not buy b friends
and have missed out on the
iconic and tectonic
roi of that investment
this is even more interesting to me
because you get 12 of these books 11 of
which you should give away to people
that you love because this is the best
book i've written since crush it we'll
get into that from regards point of view
in a minute
but on top of that
for every 12 book order which is about
300 bucks right regath yeah it's i think
it's like 20 25 each yeah it's gonna go
down by the way both barnes and nobles
and amazon whatever you buy right now
the price will go down because the way
those algorithms work is the more demand
they reset their prices and the price
goes down and by november 16th even
though you buy for 25 today it might be
19 and that's what they'll charge you
they'll refund you
for every 12 books you buy let's say you
want a hundred of these surprises
rugoff
a hundred of these surprises
on uh november 16th you can have that
you buy 1200 books
you might decide to give them out of the
conference or things that nature but
here's the bottom line
the
drop
that you'll get in your wallet
for every 12 you buy
will be a very good idea in comparison
to what you buy this is a very big deal
i'm super [ __ ] fired up the bottom
line is
it's a very good idea to buy 12 of these
books i believe
you'll regret not buying more that's how
confident i am
audiobooks
do not count because i need 12 you could
buy an extra audiobook you know hard
copies no audiobook because you can't
buy 12 audiobooks you know um
but
this is a big [ __ ] deal
i'm really excited about it and now
i and by the way a lot of people are
going to be coming in so please in the
comments section use community to let
everybody know but here's the punch line
i'm not saying it but i'm saying it
for every 12 books you buy
you will get airdropped something
that i think will make your investment
worthwhile
nice
i like it
uh this could be a big [ __ ] deal it's
also the best [ __ ] book i've written
since crush it
because it's the book that everybody's
been wanting me to write
and regard let's start this way give
everybody your story now where god was
my
partner in this book by the way
everybody please as soon as you actually
buy it
leave
in the comments because i'm you know i
live for the comments i'm seeing you all
brian seeing you mark z
secret 92 i see you i'll win gc i see
you
mate joel aldo i see you gas wolf as
soon as you buy it
please leave in here
bought and the number bought 48 bought
480 but but i'm telling you
just tap back in
to how you felt
tap back in and how you felt when you
passed on v friends and now you know
what's up
don't just buy 12
is what i'm saying now if you can't
afford 12
and you can only buy one i'm very
grateful because it's going to be one of
the best books if you can't buy any i'm
very grateful i'll continue to give out
free content thematically but this is
organized in a really interesting way
rob
tell everybody by the way
you're going to regret if you only
bought 12. just saying and by the way if
you change your mind during the stream
as you start figuring out what's [ __ ]
actually happening here actually
happening here once you figure it out
you can obviously reset and you could
buy 12 right now i some of you went fast
you bought 12 i have a funny feeling
over the next couple hours you're gonna
there's no limit adam
but you need to put them to your
strategy because everyone's gonna get
one so keep that in mind for every 12
garyvee.com book has all the info
it's i mean there's international links
right we're off so sweden this is global
we're world worldwide baby paolo my
friend who just texted me i [ __ ] love
you at garyvee.com just go to amazon
it's all there it's [ __ ] all there
if you really understand what's going on
here this is the [ __ ] crazy i've
really worked on this one for you
this is a real [ __ ] moment i'm not
kidding there's something real serious
here
please be smart
you can get a hundred bucks of course
you can okay like that's exactly be
smart listen to what i'm saying one more
time for every 12 you buy
when you upload the receipt please go to
garyvee.com
something on the 16th
when the book launches
it's gonna be
worth it
i believe that i don't think it's even
gonna cost you 300 bucks because i do
think amazon and barnes noble's price
comes down that's how they do it if
you've ever pre-owned books you
sometimes pay it but you pay less they
have an algorithm of how low they go
based on demand
let's call it 20 bucks i'm just going to
go there regav
240 bucks
for every 240 you spend for 12 of these
and don't forget you still then get 12
of them so you get to give them out
donate them sell them flip them on ebay
i don't [ __ ] know do your thing
something good is gonna happen but now
let's get into the content of the book
we'll get back to the sale this is the
right hook but this is the most unique
right hook in my life i always say give
give give and then ask and i do that
with empathy rose this is not empathy by
the way i'm drinking different rose um
my books you've seen it from iraq right
but much on the theme of the friends
people thought i was selling ragav you
even learned something right in the way
i was communicating for you people
thought i was selling something
why i wasn't i was doing something
please if you're part of the be friends
fam and you've won from this please
share your stories in instagram or in
youtube or in twitter like twitch share
your stories to what happened to you the
money you made
this is a 2.0 version of this but now
let's get into the book uh everyone's
asking for the link it's garyvee.com
everybody please put the link inside the
comments garyvee.com please leave it i
see a 36 five from chung chong thank you
it's pagesports just bought 48 thank you
danny miranda danny you need to buy more
than 48. you're a hustler i know you i
know you bought 48 i appreciate it
you're my guy we met at a book signing
when you were a kid but you're smart
listen to what i'm saying that means
you're only getting four air drops
tell us about who you are how you came
into this
yep
and then more importantly we're going to
go into what you learned and what we're
about here
yeah so i'm raghav good to meet all of
you
i've been on gary's team now for uh
close to three years september is gonna
be three years i emailed gary and
that worked out
so initially i started like three years
ago as his copywriter and then now over
time kind of starting to help out more
with just running the overall content
around the brand and everything and
during this process since like last i
think by the way
getting an extra 12 from barnes and
noble
might be a good idea
most go through amazon barnes noble's a
little unique i'm unique just just say
keep going
because most people here don't have a
barnes noble's account i know i believe
it i'm a big fan of effort
anyway
um so we've been working on this now for
the last like since like november like
november until like march or april so
uh it's been a fun process going through
this book so i think well god how long
were you on team gary actually tell us
the full team gary story how did you get
to get heart it's all hard book right
now it's not soft yet it's hard cover um
i think i could be wrong about that but
i'm pretty sure it's all hard to cover i
i cj cohen thank you for your 48 books
go ahead with god
i got here um
physical books only no kindles because
you can only buy one on the kindle you
can't buy can you buy 12 on the kindle
and then pass the people andy k i saw
your question um
did you get the amazon ranking and the
barnes noble ranking yeah well amazon
right now so it's 114 in
entrepreneurship no no overall i need
the overall
9443. 94
43 okay yep it could be number one in a
couple hours if everyone gets super here
yeah
i'm not seeing it and brian's noble okay
we'll figure that out later keep it
going instagram what's good everybody
if you're if you want to get into
more links and stuff please share the
chats uh there we go shiv shiv bought
720 books someone's using their [ __ ]
brain
just like people won heavy on be friends
people gonna win very heavy for every 12
they bought here every single person
that bought 24 is gonna regret that they
can buy 36. oh god do you regret not
buying defense i certainly do
and you were in the inner circle and you
still underestimated me like the world
underestimates me and i continue to
navigate sticking it to the
underestimation because i love the chip
on my shoulder and for the people in
here right now on a friday
notice when i do this friday afternoon
in august you know why ragoff
because some people even though they
love me and trust me chose to be at the
pool right now
got it
work
anyway how did you get in
uh
well i was
it was kind of funny i so like the plan
was for me that was to travel so i
travel a lot right so before this i was
like traveling through like southeast
asia and different places and just like
backpacking whatever and the plan was to
travel for like an extended period of
time and i saw in your vlog i apologize
for god team who's watching andy team
gary i don't know dustin like
dustin like we need to get people
answering questions in because i'm
looking at it but i want to focus on you
rogoff so we can do a real interview and
then get some q a
um
uh
team please um
please answer people's questions there's
a ton of questions and by the way i see
a lot of texts coming to me i can't see
them i'm too in the zone right now
please hit up dustin and then dustin
will put you on screen it'll be fun for
people to see people from our team
meanwhile are locked in andy katie sid
other team gary well i see all sorts of
people yet all over if you've got a
question to answer for them literally
hit up dustin we're gonna put you right
on screen yard you're gonna ask we're
gonna answer and people are gonna be
educated i saw somebody say no barnes
and nobles in sweden i can't you know
send it to an american address figure it
out like i'm doing the best i can here
and i see a lot somebody came in i'm
late what's this all about please
everybody please
everyone's like poor raghav can't answer
a [ __ ] question but i'm doing a lot
of logistics right now everything's on
garyvee.com
uh but here's the big one here's the big
one this is where everyone's gonna get
confused
the deadline
to submit for this is 24 hours from now
because what i'm doing is big time
so
let there be no confusion it's not like
i want to sell like the books are fine
the books are going to sell anyway
crushing it [ __ ] was in your like
this is a 24-hour thing so let's put
that up like
you know uh
that's so maybe in the background you
could put up some of the rules some of
the hits
bullets you know we've got
garyveebook.com maybe you make a little
hits and you can put that down here
remember these rules this is 24 hours
this expires 4 p.m eastern time 4 30 p.m
eastern time 5 p.m eastern time 5. 5 p.m
eastern tomorrow it's over
it's over
got it
uh it's international i see a lot of
people i'm from israel working by
garyvee.com book has all the
international links amazon's global
if you can't you know if you can't ship
it to you ship it to somebody else just
get that [ __ ] receipt
uh bittman
who's just said how can we prove we
bought it
easy
you got to go to this website there's a
form you have to upload the receipt
not super complicated
and then after we launch we'll make sure
those books were actually delivered and
then we will be dropping you something
if you get it we'll be dropping you
something
that's going to make it way way worth it
um so dustin make sure you're talking to
team dustin i think at 5 30 we'll do a q
a like somebody will come get two people
from the team that come in here and read
questions from the comments and just ask
me in real time so me and you will be on
where god will be on and then two other
people will be on and they'll just be
reading questions
live while so i don't have to do both
got it yep all right well god let's get
back to the origin stories
the drop is somebody said it's a drop
guaranteed of course what am i going to
ruin my reputation for 40 000 books and
give a [ __ ] and make four cents i made
more on [ __ ] royalties from b friends
today than the [ __ ] book of course
it's guaranteed it's my [ __ ] name
everything with me is guaranteed my
reputation's my [ __ ] life
[ __ ]
good
nice
how i got onto gary right
um
it's so three years ago i i was like i
was try i was planning on traveling for
a while like for the next several months
at the time and then i was watching a
dailyvee
and then you were like i think at the
time you're like
you're looking for a writer to help with
your quora answers
or something is like i'm looking for a
writer to like transcribe my quora
um
articles or something like that so then
i just like hit you up through email and
then you cc'd andy and then we kind of
just went from there and then that
worked out so
that was
that was uh it took a lot of follow-up
like because like i i didn't i didn't
get like responses for like the first
two or three so i think i followed up
like six times the first time around
it's actually really funny so like i uh
i thought that
once i got the offer i thought that i
actually didn't get it because once i
was once once i had the combo that i got
it i saw somebody else on a video later
like reading an article or something and
i also just didn't hear back so i was
like oh like maybe they just whatever
like they might have just gone with
somebody else but then that wasn't true
and i got in so hold on
um one second i'm resetting instagram
everybody the experience is much better
on youtube
um
uh
also uh i'm gonna reset it hold on
regard i'm sorry tell everybody more
keep going so i can um
um that was kind of it so like i came in
started as a copywriter working on the
blog working on articles working on
gary's email and things like that
and it was
it was really fun process i really
enjoyed being on the team from that
period of time like i think that
if i would describe the culture i would
say it's like it's very accepting
there's like a lot of trust involved and
like that's something i've noticed with
gary too over the last seven eight
months there's just like
like the level of trust that was given
on day one with all the
accounts or with all the with all the
stuff that's happening on the team was
very surprising to me and it was really
it was really cool and like continues to
be like a thing you know like in the
last event and now now that you're a
leader on team gary andy who used to be
the lead of team gary moves he's now the
president of be friends sid elevates up
we got may who's a major player for us
she's insane she's got a secret project
she's doing so all of a sudden you katie
like some some of you are finding new
leadership roles
you were trained with trust
you're now bringing that same thing to
the table i assume yeah
yeah 100 and it's
it's it's insane to the level that you
did it i think is what was
not surprising but always continues to
make an impression like even writing
this you know
let's talk about this so you're on my
team you're writing with me
you're capturing my voice we go over all
the things so every word is right
um i'm mainly telling you i always have
to transcribe because i don't want any
word to not be me so we're doing blog
post this now the other thing then you
get tapped on the shoulder because
stephanie land big shout out stephanie
land it's the first book i put out
without her i miss her terribly but her
career exploded because we were so
successful together so now you get
tapped for this what runs through your
head
that i've never written a book before
were you like why is gary even
considering this or you knew because we
were writing instagram it's better on
youtube if you need me but there's the
link garyvee.com all the details you're
hearing
uh big big airdrop if you buy 12 books
all details on the site go ahead
yeah i've never written a book before
and
i think
yeah like
it kind of surprised me a little bit but
also not
um
but yeah like it was
am i scared
not scared it was more like okay like i
need to like figure i need to like
understand how to like do this all right
i understand like what the
what it means to like write a book you
know
so
it was it was different
by the way you somebody just asked can i
upload two receipts i believe as you sit
here and hang out with me this evening
most of you will buy more receipts than
one so if you submit
we will sort by names and address we
will figure that out so
if you submit 12 when you got excited up
front and now you're hearing me about
and you're listening to people comment
and you're hearing the stories about be
friends nft and you're starting to put
the pieces together
then then
uh you if you buy another 48 that will
count so don't worry about that
everybody's asking a ton of questions
garyvee.com book it's right here it's
linked please everybody who's hardcore
from the vaynernation please get that
url and tell everybody to read that post
expense explains everything keep going
rogoff
yeah everybody's saying where to submit
where to submit please everybody please
help people submit
to this url has all the info
yeah um
surprise when i got tapped for it so i
was like how do i how do i write this
how do we figure this out like what does
it mean to write something in your own
words
what's this book about
i think it if i describe it it it helps
bridge the gap between
um the
loftier concepts that you talk about so
you talk about kindness there's
accountability there's all these
different traits but i think people
really struggle with
like making the gap bridging the gap
between how does that actually help in
running a business like you talk about
like kindness isn't r is roi positive
for example but it's like i think the
reaction that people have sometimes is
like what but how though like or like
how or like why so i think the way we
laid this out breaks that down
keep going because this is really big
because like you came in
you knew of me but you didn't really
know like you really [ __ ] know now
you're like really under the hood i'm
super transparent you see everything
there's no hiding in my world then you
got really really really into this
like
actually one of the reasons i knew i was
writing a great book was how you were
evolving during the book process let's
go there how did you change
two things how did you change
you
by writing this book
how did your perception of me or that's
doesn't have to go there
how did you
how did you
um
how do you understand me or the success
better because of it
i think the way that i changed was
so i think i think the biggest thing
that this book does
is
it gives you tools to use and makes you
like more
conscious and being able to use them so
like i think i think the the you know
some of the ingredients we talk about is
like humility patience hold on one
second
shout out alert i gotta do shout out
alerts you're gonna bear me with me here
zero i see you with your 24 thank you so
much when you get your two surprises
in november you're gonna [ __ ] be
happy
in december if you decide to transact my
friends
this is
a big deal please don't miss today
please don't miss today
go ahead
yeah i think so i would say the way that
i changed is like
so one if i if i look at all these
ingredients in the book we talk about
all these different traits right my
weakest one as i was going through it
was conviction
i think we could we talked about
you remember those couple of first days
during the draw i was so happy for the
people that supported me yeah knowing
that many people didn't support me like
this is gonna be a big day like a lot of
people this is perfect notice how i
promoted this it's kind of like a hard
promotion in my world
but i didn't go outside of my world this
is [ __ ] v friends launch all over
again
i'm really excited about it i just know
what's going to happen so i'm excited
still
it's super dope people are going to have
the best book i've ever written
this book's going to change people's
lives you know that right
i know all right let's go back to you
i'm sorry i'm interrupting you left and
right but i can't help because i got to
talk to the community but yeah it
changed you how because i want to listen
i've been looking too much in the
comments i'm in with you now go
instagram please go to youtube
um
so like so if i think one thing we
talked about was um my biggest
weakness or the half as you call it in
this book
is
is conviction and kind candor because
like i was i really struggled a lot of
times with like i think like so my
biggest strength out of this list would
be curiosity
and i think because we lean into that
because i try to lean into that a lot i
think that i struggle with sometimes
like
stating an opinion you know instead of
being like this is it i would be like
i'd rather like ask you another question
you know what i mean so like so i i
sometimes like especially in different
environments i apologize my friend
dustin can you talk to team a lot of
people asking hard book paperback i
don't even think the book comes in
paperback but if it does
and i think it might like great it's 12
bucks right in whatever shape or size
you know
i don't think there's that option at all
i don't think it's either anyway
everybody who's buying 12.
hardcover is what we are pushing yeah
it's not that i don't give a [ __ ]
actually it's just what i think it is i
think paperback comes it comes out after
countries yeah in some countries
whatever it is it is
uh people are saying it's out of stock
in india
um
we'll confirm that we'll get some
details if we have to do a special thing
for a country it's sold out in we'll
figure that out
um but the link please if you're asking
questions garyvee.com
book has a lot of the answers and it's
why we built the blog post it's got the
international links keep going
is barnes noble's crashed because
it should release the same day in india
keep going my man okay
um
where was i
let's start from the top
what changed in you
you said conviction was something you
struggle with what raghav just said the
book is called 12 and a half leveraging
the emotional ingredients necessary for
business success
i believe that i'm going to be one of
the greatest businessmen of all time
because of who my mom was and how she
raised me from an emotional intelligence
standpoint this book breaks down
emotional traits
i don't have the actual book what are
the 12 and a half ak-13 in this book i
get very vulnerable
i talk about the 13
human traits that i think are
responsible for great leadership and
great business building i called it 12
and a half because one of them i don't
think i'm good at
i'm not good at it and so i called it 12
and a half
because
i'm still going through my journey and
some of you might be seven and a half
and 11 and a half
and so i am going through my journey
so i'm
in a place where i'm very vulnerable
about something called kind candor
because i'm candorous as garyvee
um i'm candace instagram as garyvee
um but
uh
i'm not candace enough and it hurts me
as gary vaynerchuk right and so
um
i made it a half now we're jumping all
over the place people are coming in at
different times i see a lot of people
who are lost and confused please
everyone tell
um tell everybody what's happening here
and point everybody to garyvee.com
book if maybe 15 to 20 people in these
live streams can take the lead and just
repeat the doc the url over and over if
you need to know what's going on click
here
i'm aware that india's sold out i'm
aware barnes and noble's website has
crashed
we'll we'll deal with the aftermath of
this after the fact
um
so the book is built around the
emotional do you have the emotional
yeah here we go so everybody this book
covers the following things
so these are the these are the traits
gratitude self-awareness
accountability
optimism
empathy
kindness tenacity curiosity patience
conviction humility ambition
and kind candor
thank you
uh quickly some people are saying my
site's down let's confirm that this is
out of control
um
so regard what you learned about
yourself during it was that your
you struggle with conviction
out of these yeah like out of these 12
and a half that we do like conviction
stood out is a weakness
and
and
are you different now
yeah i mean so this is a process it's a
process to build it and i think it's
it's it's uh
it's hard to develop some of these
things but i think that it made it
easier to get me over the edge to like
have some of those conversations i need
to do
to develop conviction you know like some
of the exercises in the book the
scenarios that you break down
the scenarios are huge scenarios really
helped me
like
tell everybody what we did um with the
scenarios
yeah so i guess for context the book is
broken down into three parts
uh the first part is like these traits
like gratitude self-awareness all the
stuff that i just listed out so the
first part is like gary talking about
all the traits the second part is how do
you use those traits in different
business situations like oh the
like
a business partner stole money from me
or like oh i'm managing someone who's
older than me or something like that and
then the last part of the book is
exercises like little tasks and stuff
like oh how do you by the way i saw one
spammer say
buy 12 and then return it we're gonna
wait for the airdrop to make sure the
books were delivered you're more than
welcome to return it if you're a piece
of [ __ ] keep going why not donate to the
library why not give it to people
[ __ ] [ __ ] go ahead
uh yeah that's it that that's how the
book is that's how it looks you learned
about me what did you what gave you ahas
and so oh that's how gary's building an
empire
i think the bigot the biggest thing is
creating safety
is what stands out
creating safety
for people to have
conversations and i'm not sure what
trait that falls into i think that's
that's a lot of them empathy
that's
i think empathy is probably a huge one
that came up a lot in the book
writing process accountability but like
making people feel safe enough around
you to one i think
just be themselves like just
express like who they are and stuff
around you in a more like
genuine way
and then also having and then the other
parts having the conversations with you
that they might not have
so i think safety is huge
talk to ever so everybody i wanted to
talk about these traits that i think
have been dominant in my business
success i can tell you right now every
single company
if you have a company of employees
please please buy you know what i'm so
excited about is this is the mastermind
of today's event
i know that a lot of you [ __ ] with me i
know a lot of you regret not buying beef
friends i know it's a combination for
this moment i'm doing it because i want
to sucker you this is the word i'm going
to use sucker you into buying 120 of
these because i know this is the most
important book i've ever written when it
comes to business because i'm [ __ ]
out here trying to change the narrative
of business it's not about sharp elbows
or who's the toughest it's who's the
kindest who's the most human
right
i know that i'm gonna drop you something
after you buy these
this winter
that's going to be
potentially not financial advice
more valuable than the [ __ ] books you
bought so you're going to buy these 480
and then you're going to have 40 of
these assets and then you're gonna have
transactional operation this is insane
you're gonna make money potentially not
financial advice by buying this book
but then you're gonna have 48 of these
books show up and be like what the [ __ ]
and you're gonna give them to human
beings and if they read this [ __ ]
book their life is gonna change not
their business life their [ __ ] life
look up what what else from that journey
like what what were they ahas because
the way we structured it is we talked
about why they were important and then
we did scenarios and i got into story
time
the scenarios you reading in a full like
what was the big aha
how did you see like for example there
was like my favorite one my favorite
scenario out of all of them was like so
they're just real quick real quick i
apologize for the worse i'm killing you
this is only a 24-hour thing
uh uh
dustin i should not be drinking rose uh
dustin
this is already halfway home dustin can
you please put in the bottom garyvee.com
but can you also put oh there you go you
gotta scroll in the bottom you're the
[ __ ] best
you cannot buy at any time to get the
airdrop you have to buy it in the next
24 hours
ebooks count but you have to buy 12 in
one receipt
keep going
um so there was one scenario about i'll
read it out it was
it was you're growing a service based
business you've been consistently
pitching new prospects and you can and
you find that they're always excited at
first but once you mention your price
they typically disappear and you never
hear from them again you've had good
paying clients in the past who are happy
to pay your rate and they were satisfied
with your work but you're not sure how
to find them consistently what would you
do so like that like that read one more
i like this i like that we're giving
people a little preview to the book yeah
i'll get it i did scenarios here friends
so that you guys could have
feels
like
this book look at that little piggy
look at that 12 and a half to the bank
this is [ __ ] business i've been
trying to [ __ ] tell all of you being
nice caring about your employees more
than your [ __ ] wallet i care more
about regard than this [ __ ] wallet
that's why this wallet's gonna be fat as
[ __ ]
you [ __ ] are confused out here
being nice is how you win
you're not [ __ ] impressing anybody by
[ __ ] ripping people off you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
it's [ __ ] kindness look what's going
on in the piggy bank [ __ ] hearts dick
face
[ __ ] heart stick face it's [ __ ]
kindness be nice
be [ __ ] nice
[ __ ]
should i should i read one more
i love that jay lee just said he under
promises and over delivers and i promote
so hard i go so hard i
promise so heavy that people don't get
it they're usually confused when it's
this hard of a right hook
they don't understand what i'm [ __ ]
dropping for them they understand what
i'm gonna do with those tokens
you don't [ __ ] understand what i'm
gonna do for you
pay a [ __ ] tension
a lot of you [ __ ] missed and [ __ ]
doubted me didn't believe me thought it
was a scam thought i was short term
people out here bought [ __ ] v friends
for two thousand bucks and [ __ ] sold
it for ninety thousand three weeks later
i get an email every day from people
that paid off their college debt paid
their mom's [ __ ] medical [ __ ]
bills people [ __ ] went crazy
[ __ ]
pay attention today buy your 12 books
buy your 120 books donate them give them
to every employee give them to every
co-worker [ __ ] sell them all on ebay
i don't give a [ __ ] burn them i don't
give a [ __ ]
don't burn them give me people so they
read it because i want people to [ __ ]
understand that nice and kind and good
is how you're gonna win somebody's
addict to you somebody's a racist to you
somebody says sexist to you somebody
shits on you you [ __ ] nail it back
with kindness
heat on hate doesn't do [ __ ]
[ __ ]
oh god
this is the best
uh scenarios you wanna
want us to read like two or three how do
you want to read one more scenario that
we put in the book read one more yeah
you're running by the way by the way
dust i know i'm just doing this to you
left and right the instagram i'm sorry
you gotta watch us on youtube thus i may
bring in people to ask questions
and nobody from team gary wants to come
on here
i can't hear you
still candy
i know it's out of stock in india we're
gonna have to figure something out we're
gonna get him back restocked
sid or tyler or andy can we call hollis
i'm gonna call house my um i got [ __ ]
instagram live instagram i'm gonna go
offline for a second go to youtube or
twitter i'll be back in a second nah i'm
not gonna kill it
i can do it actually here hold on
sid katie and sh uh sether
sets about the joint hey oh i'm calling
hollis
from india this is my publisher at
harper give me one second everyone
keep talking with god while i do this
i'll bring out one more so this is one
more scenario from the book hi alex part
two
so
this live we're doing is going very well
but in
india sold out people freaking out
india i guess amazon india barnes and
noble's website crashed
yeah there's a lot going on so we're
gonna need to can you email the team and
like
we you know because i'm doing only a
24-hour thing with these receipts and
india's up in india's mad
the whole country of india is mad
by the by the way we're also gonna have
to cut down some trees we were selling a
[ __ ] load of books
yeah no i get it but like
our our
yeah anyway we'll have to regroup
tomorrow i know it's friday but like you
know i want to make sure that the people
that wanted to win here in places that
got screwed can win so let's figure that
out okay
somebody else just said mexico says one
max order like basically amazon what am
i yeah
makes sense amazon wasn't ready for the
vayner nation and india is [ __ ] mad
so we got to figure it out and we ki and
barnes nobles is dead
broken
okay okay just
i love you see ya okay bye
all right
a lot going on just talk to harper
collins
they uh got some work to do um all right
good to see the beautiful faces seth
katie what do you got for me
we're here to answer some questions
please
okay
um so the first ones we saw you will
need you cannot use a coin based wallet
you will need a metamask wallet yeah you
need a non-custodial wallet so i can
drop off if you have a coinbase you
should have a meta mask now or a rainbow
i need that address
uh
i need a non-custodial
go to my go to my website
garyvaynerchuk.com type in nft read all
the 101s
the other thing i'm just going to repeat
100 000 times i need more people in the
comments helping garyvee.com book has
all the information people are asking
very basic one-on-one questions it's all
there but keep going katie and seth
while i drink more rose to get myself
crazy
i wish i was too
um so this is a great one where someone
asked if they filled out the form but
didn't give any confirmation email how
do we know guys we have it um we will
reach out to you
um between now and
no problem that's a great point yeah we
will email we will get that going good
point yes yes
um seth you got anything
uh what do we need to have set up to
receive the airdrop in november you need
to have a meta mask or a rainbow account
because
we're not asking yet for their address
right in the form
their wallet address dresser are we i
didn't look at the we are we are but
it's not required right we'll do it
we'll do it again as well but for all of
you that are crypto savvy and a lot of
you should be because we've been [ __ ]
educating for nine months when you
upload your receipt on
garyvee.com wherever they're sending you
put in your wallet address if between
now and we're gonna do another
confirmation because i know some of you
will get hacked unfortunately some may
change we will do a multi
um
uh
touchin with all of you
um
sorry i'm getting texts from
harpercollins they're freaking out um
uh we'll make sure before we drop it
we're gonna confirm as much as we can
that we have the right
wallet that we're dropping the surprise
on we're getting very direct with what
we're actually doing here by the way if
you only bought 12
make it another 24. seth katie keep
going
and if they don't have a metamask wallet
we can work with them to help them get
it set up but um
they send them send them
like let's put in dustin let's get
somebody on the team dropping
um all the information
of like how to set up accounts from 137
or garyvaynerchuk.com let's keep
educating and again there's so many ogs
of the community in here please
please please please
um
if you're in there please keep linking
all the accounts
um
please keep linking sorry about that
everybody on instagram i know you've uh
stopped this i'm gonna start again um
please keep sharing these links and keep
answering the questions i need you today
there's a lot going on there's a lot of
people here it's only a 24-hour thing a
lot of people are going to miss out
and i don't want that to be the case
right
um
keep going team uh another question was
are multiple receipts okay or can we
bulk order in one receipt for more than
one both are okay we're going to be able
to find everything
do you have to buy and submit
your receipts in 24 hours or just
now and submit
between if it's bought with it if it's
bought within the 24 hours as long as
you have that receipt you can always
submit any time you don't have to submit
within 24 hours
and by the way india's down barnes noble
is broken
um you know so i'll adjust
links are in the youtube description now
great work dust please i really need
like 15 people on youtube periscope
linkedin twitch and facebook to kind of
like really take the lead on the links
go ahead
is it okay if they blur out their
address on the receipts
yes i have no interest in your
information i just need to know that you
bought it so i can drop it for you i
don't need to show up at your house i
don't give a [ __ ] you absolutely can
blur it out maybe you want to show up at
their house
most will want me to show up in their
house but i will not be showing up
uh can it be an ebook kindle kindle
order
yeah but i don't think you can buy 12
ebooks for 12 kindles so i think you
need to buy a 12 receipt and then buy a
13th book you can't don't [ __ ] me up and
buy 11 and then try to leave like some
weird notes saying but i bought an ebook
too like be a friend
adam i promise you what you're going to
get in surprise is going to make it
worth your time
12 receipt orders in hard book
and then if you need a kindle
or
an e-book or an audio book for yourself
because that's how you're actually going
to consume the best [ __ ] book i've
ever written
that's fine so you have 13. it's okay
there's one entry per second right now
that's why
that's no no it's not wild people
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and [ __ ]
slept on me including you for [ __ ]
and didn't buy a v friend you four
[ __ ] might not have had the money and
i respect that
but
people [ __ ] on me and [ __ ]
underestimated me and i [ __ ] punch
them in the face by giving them 20 x
returns
do you know what it feels like to buy
something for [ __ ] point five and
fourth two thousand dollars and then
reselling it for sixty five thousand
dollars sixty days later
yeah that's what [ __ ] happened you
four
is it amazon screenshot receipt okay
yes but you should get the email and
that's yes but yes yes
did you say barnes and noble purchase is
more valuable than an amazon purchase
i'm being cute i've got something clever
that i'm working on
i think an additional barnes noble 12 is
just a good idea
i'm clever bookstores
all right i'm going to let you guys keep
looking
what else in this book stood out
for you
one more time because people are just
joining what's this book about from your
words and then i'll give it for my words
um i think this book so it read it kind
of redefines what it means to be a smart
business person is how i think about it
in my head
so it
like when you think about a smart
business decision or a smart business
person you think a lot about like oh
like someone who's out maneuvering
somebody else or someone who's stepping
on somebody else and this kind of like
bridges the gap between how or it
redefines it
of what a smart
business person a business person or
like a business decision means to
something that's more kind empathetic
warm
gratitude
stuff like that i feel like like like
the best lion in the book was in the
intro when you were like
um
business is normally seen as doggy dog
or like only the strong survive and
ironically you also believe that only
the strong survive as i said these are
the traits of actual strength yeah i
think strength is empathy and kindness
and
all that [ __ ] you just got a word that
ebooks don't count
okay
because you can't buy 12 ebooks
right
you know like i said i mean look
we'll do the work if somebody bought an
ebook and then submitted 11 hard copies
but this is for 12 hard copies like of
course we'll look nate slalom like if
we'll look carefully if you submit twice
and show the receipts
we'll look carefully but like
please if you bought like
if you already did it that's fine we'll
figure it out but like to streamline
this it's 12 hard cut every 12
increments hard copy book
the
the ebook the audio book let that make
that be an incremental like it's 20
bucks more there is no soft copy books
everyone's asking for soft covers
there's no soft covers
yet
team what the reason i wrote this book
is that i'm very bad at putting my
thoughts on paper
i'm very good at putting my thoughts up
in audio and if you've been following me
religious for ten years seven years five
years you can figure it out but it's
hard
it's like hard to figure it out
this book is probably the first time
i've really collectively like
really [ __ ] put it on paper and was
like this is the [ __ ] jam
like this is how you will succeed in
life and actually in business
um by the way if there's soft covers in
europe i hear that amazing great then
put in 12 book orders amazing i count
all physical books of hard or soft and
12 orders i also recommend to all of you
you will have regret
in one man's point of view if you only
buy 12 because the strategy here is to
really really uk's got hard soft cover
is great
really [ __ ] win for you
really win for you
i'm dropping you some [ __ ]
like this is gonna really matter
really matter
are uh still asking where do you put the
receipt and it's on garyvee.com book and
you scroll down
uh to the bottom there's a form that you
can draw as many attachments
also linked on screen
yes
those still asking about hard covers
versus paper
uh how do we update our info if we buy
more and already submitted uh just
submit a second
a second time
one second team
okay uh what was that
uh someone was asking how do we update
our info if we've already submitted uh
and the answer is just submit a second
time that's right submit multiple times
team one more time
uh to recap if you're just joining us i
have a new book coming out called 12 and
a half which talks about the emotional
the emotional ingredients
that are necessary for business success
i believe in this the most actually
while i got you seth katie dustin
talk about me doing a move
on you know don't gass me up this is
just to teach people because they don't
believe me maybe all four of you didn't
believe me from the outside talk to me
about an
out of the ordinary move that i've done
with you
that
you don't think is common for a boss
that meant something
to you katie you go first
i have a good one um and it was my first
day on the job and i came and i was
sitting down in the lobby and you came
in and winked at me which was one thing
and so just the acknowledgement from you
like as the ceo was something big i
remember texting my mom about it
um and then
i
was sitting at my desk and you came over
you said hey katie welcome to the team
and i was just like
awesome let's go let's get started
because it was just something that i was
like wow he really cared about me
joining his team when there's like 30
people on it how would he know my name
how would he know who i was and that was
even joining the team so
um that mean a lot to me on my
first day thank you
seth you've been around a little longer
this could be interesting yeah one that
really stands out to me i think it was
it was within my first month um
and you know i was brand new to the team
bringing into the company uh and you or
you or somebody else had pulled me into
a meeting with you and some big wigs of
chase for uh an askgaryvee that we did
uh and that plus the fact that i was
asked questions and give them the
opportunity to give my opinion on on
thing for this episode specifically
blew my mind because it was like you
know these these big name people and
just me was brand new to this company
and i was given trust to you know that
my opinion would matter and that
something that i would say wasn't you
know a complete dumb idea
i love it before we get to dust ethan
shaffer goes why 12. no problem the
reason i want you to buy 12 is because
the book is called 12 and a half and i
didn't want to be greedy and make it 13.
so i let you buy one less book to get
surprised that's why
dust
um
i just remember this time
where uh i was editing something and i
added something that wasn't supposed to
be on there
and i think initially you were like what
the [ __ ] happened
and then i was like i [ __ ] up and
you're like don't worry like it's fine
like
you understood that it happened when i
thought i was like gonna get fired
i know what you're talking about we got
really negative feedback and i had a
24-hour kind of window on like a story
about something i did and like
it got taken out of context because the
way we edited it yeah and you thought
you were in deep [ __ ] because it was bad
right yeah
and were you like stunned like
those are my by the way dust your
stories might i love seth and katie but
that matters to me like that really
[ __ ] me up
and i
still knew it was my response that you
know regard you know this you've gotten
really in my head i counted go ahead i
see you want to go there well that too
like i relate to like i feel like i've
made more mistakes like that than
anybody else on the team since the time
that i've been here like at least in the
first part you know like having been
writing and stuff like that so i've
noticed that a lot um there's a lot of
safety to make those mistakes
and so what that's like that was like
big for you like you like genuinely
actually thought you might get fired is
that true
um
yeah like i think i thought well i
wasn't sure i was like oh crap i'm
[ __ ]
and instead i came with like
accountability and kindness
i remember you specifically said i have
empathy for that
i was like
my i was like
i was really surprised that
you asked me to write like
your sixth
like major book when i have never done
it before
and i think that
speaks to trust
i love that
katie back to you because we're really
everybody yes we have this big moment
there's a big day
like we are a hundred percent doing
something that everybody will remember
which is you're gonna buy 12 of the best
books of all time maybe
and then something amazing is going to
happen to you in return this is my
favorite day ever
99 of you [ __ ] up with me friends
[ __ ] up
like you think they're expensive now
with 30 50 100 000 piece i'm gonna stick
it to you so heavy i'm not going to stop
until they're a million dollars a piece
and then dustin is going to like talk to
his like child and be like i could have
bought it for two thousand dollars
his team i was doing t with garyvee
every day i was close and i still
understand
anyway
but now here's another chance to do
something really cool where this will be
an roi positive event for you
emotionally and financially is my great
passion many of you bought 12
i want to make sure that you buy another
36 and submit another receipt because i
know exactly what the [ __ ] i'm doing
what we're talking about is being a
great person being a great boss building
a big business even if you have one
employee or like i have 1500
and we're talking to people that are
close to me on team gary we're jamming
out seems like the uk amazon is now out
of books
again team we [ __ ] up india sounds
like we [ __ ] up the uk
i just want to make sure everybody knows
because we only have 24 hours to submit
these receipts if it's true that
everyone's out of stock we will
absolutely do this one more time work
with amazon and others to make sure
because i'll never [ __ ] let you not
get a piece of this anyway amy going
back to you we asked the biggest thing
that happened to you
as a manager because this is about
treating people well as a manager
talk to me about another story
the truth this is the [ __ ] truth
don't gass me up i want people to hear
this [ __ ] because they don't believe the
[ __ ] they say you guys
do all four of you feel like sometimes
when you talk to people
they they come at you when they know
what you do
thinking that who i am on camera is like
full of [ __ ] and then you have to
explain to them that i'm even better
than that person that's on camera talk
to me about that i see all of you just
reacted it's like the first question
everyone always asks yeah really is he
really like that yep
talk antidotes anecdotes help teach
people the yeah
the the
it doesn't get you go for it i i
completely lost my train of thought
there that's just that's just every
person's first question hey is he really
like that and i'm like what do you mean
i mean
they're like usually i think they just
mean like loud and like cursing and
stuff like that
but i say
like yeah i mean yeah but like in person
he's just
a normal person like
it's not like
i don't know he's not trying to
i get more even right now as you guys
know even right now i'm more excitable
like when i know there's eyes stage
camera
something happens to my tech you know my
chemicals that takes me up
but in real life i also don't think that
people realize that i'm running a major
business definitely no people think i'm
like they just think you're a
motivational speaker yeah katie
yeah um i mean when i do the orientation
uh for vayner a lot of people's first
question is like is he really the way he
is on in content um and it's always
just reiterating the fact that you're
human and you want to meet everybody and
i think that's like
one of your biggest brand ethos is like
that you're just a human being and um
that's what i always lead with um
another based on
people not
realizing just like how good you are at
branding i would say because like gary v
versus gary vaynerchuk people know you
as gary vee from social media so like so
many people would come into the office
and be like what what the [ __ ] is this
and like not understand that there's
like a thousand people working for
vaynermedia and
working
like that you are a ceo first of all
that you're an entrepreneur like people
just um assume i guess like
motivational speaker social media guru
like people don't understand that
you are a ceo as well and so i always
thought that was so funny when people
come in they're like just stunned by the
office
yeah i think one that stands out to me
is uh people ask is he the same person
as you see online and on stage and i'd
say yes but when you talk to him
one-on-one it's a completely different
experience
he's not like sitting you're not sitting
there screaming at me back at you know
what i'm asking or what i'm saying it's
a normal conversation with a normal
human being
i thank you team team uh a lot of people
asking questions to recap i'm announcing
that i have a new book out 12 and a half
what you're hearing is from my employees
that are close to me on team gary about
different stories
i
people are so cynical like i wish you
knew that this is what they're actually
saying behind my back not that they're
pressured to say nice [ __ ] in front of
me
i by the way i genuinely believe what
i'm about to say they're probably nicer
to me behind my back because it feels
awkward to do it here in front of me
i believe that that is why this book is
the most important book i've read
written excuse me
i believe that people are very confused
of what it takes to be a big winner i
believe that i'm going to build one of
the biggest companies
organizations
i'm going to be one of the most
successful entrepreneurs of all time on
the back of what i write about here
ragav here on block 2 in my screen was
my partner in writing this book he's
been on team gary for a while and what
we're doing today is a real giveaway for
everybody who has fomo that they missed
out on the friends
99 of my community [ __ ] up on vfriends
so i wanted to give them a chance so
what i'm doing today is for every 12 and
all the information is at garyvee.com
book for everybody buys
this book in 12 book improvements for
every 12 books you buy 12 24 36 360.
uh you go to a form on garyvee.com book
you upload the information you attach
your receipt which you have to buy now
it expires in 24 hours as you can see
the rolling thing on the bottom
and
in november i'm going to drop you a
surprise
at this point it's so obvious what i'm
doing
i'll just go there i'm going to create a
very special nft
that i'm going to airdrop for every 12
you bought so if you buy 120 you're
going to get 10 of these nfts
i'm excited what i'm going to do with
that nft i want to over deliver even
with my hyperbole somebody said is this
an infomercial it is not
it's a [ __ ] guy who's on his way to
being one of the greatest entrepreneurs
of all time living his process and
trying to over deliver for his audience
because he gets more enjoyment of people
winning than he gets from his own
winning even though he gets plenty of
enjoyment from his own winning this is
just one next chapter in my world pun
intended
please don't make the same mistake you
made with v-prince if you bought 12 buy
another 12. you could submit three times
four times if you bought 120 buy another
120.
i only promoted this so much
i didn't try to go overboard we did a
little something a solid promotion
there's not that many of you watching
this right now there's not gonna be that
many tokens
and then it's gonna be a thing
[ __ ] get your mind right a lot of you
[ __ ] up there's a cheap way to get in
the game
oh god what for the people who are just
joining what is the book about from your
words as my partnerness i know india is
sold out i just saw it i know the uk
sold out we're going to try to make it
up to all of you we're going to figure
out after the fact i know it expires in
24 hours there may be a chance for
certain parts of the world we'll do this
again i'm going to figure it out
what's the book about
it it breaks down why the traits of
business success or like it kind of
redefines what a smart smart business
person or a smart business decision is
is how i think about it in my head
so instead of like sharp elbows instead
of maneuvering people instead of
stepping on people being the perception
of what a smart business person is it's
more like oh a kind person is
is a smart business person actually i
think like intuition is something that
we emphasized a lot in this book
throughout
and i think that's a big parallel that
people are gonna take away from this
like yeah when we were making this book
we were trying to really capture the
essence
talk to me about
the breakthrough of the scenarios and
then read somebody a new scenario that
we came up with
the breakthrough of the scenarios was
like we were trying to figure out what
was the best container to
communicate like
like tie in these traits to a business
environment so when we were thinking
about like how do you tie gratitude into
business we figured out that the best
way to do it was to for me to read gary
a scenario and that gary reacts to that
scenario
assuming that he was the person in that
scenario and talks about how he would
use gratitude for example
to deal with that situation
um i'll get the book out
sorry guys i have a quick question that
uh might be an important one um target
only allows 10 copies at a time so can i
buy 10 copies and then buy two copies
and upload two separate receipts yes
by the way will grove's looking for that
i just went into the discord
i'm watching of how many books people
bought
and i'm trying to remind people that you
can't mint a [ __ ] pfp project right
now for less than 300.
you can't mint
a [ __ ] nft for 300.
12 of these books is 300.
get [ __ ] smart everybody please don't
do what you did with be friends
please
i got one
you've been working at a company for
several years
people around you appreciate your work
but you still feel like you're underpaid
you know the company's having budget
cuts so you don't want to be insensitive
but you also feel like you deserve more
money what would you do
so in that situation you did it one more
time i want everybody to hear this
you've you've been working at a company
for several years
people around you appreciate your work
but you still feel that you're underpaid
you know that the company is having
budget cuts so you don't want to be
insensitive but you also feel like you
deserve more money given the value you
would bring so what would you do that's
thinking about that
think about that
think about like just think about how
[ __ ] huge that is
it's a reality
it's a real situation read one more
brother
so you have the soft cover book you
actually i have a fake book i have a
fake book everyone because we need it
for this what's really here is this
ragoff you have a real one right i have
the printed galley yes
i love that i wish i had it one
one more scenario please because i want
people to understand this book is gonna
[ __ ] change lives which is once again
why i'm trying to trick you let me be
very clear
seth katie i'm being very clear here
i know that if people are listening
carefully i'm being very literal that
they realize wait a minute i need to buy
as many of these as possible because
gary's going to airdrop me an nft it's
me worth more than the [ __ ] books
[ __ ]
[ __ ] already jesus pay attention
but why am i doing that because i know
that nobody needs 96 of these
but if they have 96 of them what are
they going to do
my hope is they're going to donate it to
the library my hope is that they're
going to bring it to the office and put
a little sign that says free i want the
message out
i'm gonna make people make money by
extending the message that kindness
is [ __ ] finally ready to dominate
business
when i die that is what they're gonna
[ __ ] say
that he [ __ ] made kindness
the rule of business because that's what
i [ __ ] do you four know it they don't
believe me they're cynical you know
they're cynical that's why everybody
asks you they don't believe me they
think i'm full of [ __ ] because people
can't believe good they're scared to
believe in good because they don't want
to be let down
[ __ ]
i hope people understand what's
happening here
don't make a mistake people you [ __ ]
up with me friends and i stuck it to you
don't make me stick this one to you you
got 24 hours you've got 24 [ __ ] hours
to not make a mistake get your friends
to buy 12. they're going to get into the
nft game everyone's crying it's too
expensive 300 bucks you're getting empty
it's better [ __ ] 99 of the [ __ ]
[ __ ] pfe projects that are coming
out here you [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
regav
why you always made me follow that how
do i kind of make fun of it
the uk is sold out of soft covers people
were playing the arbitrage of soft
covers being less expensive buy the hard
covers i'm not promising you anything in
india or uk i'm probably going to come
back but the hardcovers aren't that much
more expensive you're going to win on
the nfts
and if you bought 12 please
if you can afford it be [ __ ] smart
you can't [ __ ] mint a [ __ ] nft
for 300 bucks
so so these are pre-orders so it should
nothing should be sold out right
well the websites didn't anticipate this
kind of level yeah i think people just
need to restart their pager no no no
amazon's out of stock on some of them
we're gonna have to go back to them load
it up again and maybe extend this for 24
hours in some markets gotcha
um people asking how
they
what kind of confirmation they can get
that their uh received submission went
through we're gonna email everybody to
confirm if you don't see it by october
1st reach out to us
scenario yeah i got one
you're a business you're a business
owner who's consistently been putting
out audio video and written content on
social platforms for the last two months
you've noticed a little bit of follower
growth but you haven't had any customers
coming through social media you're
trying to understand whether you're on
the right track or not or whether you
should adjust your strategy so what
would you do
i didn't listen to what you said because
i'm talking with sid one more time
you're a business owner who's
consistently been putting out audio
video and written content across social
platforms for the past two months
you've noticed a little bit of follower
growth but you haven't had any customers
coming through social media you're
trying to understand
whether you're on the right track or not
or whether you keep going or adjust your
strategy i love that that's so many
instagram please please please go to
youtube
please go to garyvee.com to restart this
in a minute
um
yeah man that's like that's why i love
this book the scenarios are crazy look
up read the first
two pages
[ __ ] it let's have some fun
one question in the interim one yeah do
a couple questions while god gets ready
um someone said they bought it with
their wife's account amazon account
doesn't matter that their name is on the
receipt versus the person
well now we
we're going to go unlike a lot of people
who think i'm fake on video and then not
we're going to go with a lot of trust in
here
somebody wants to scam us that's fine
i'm going to double check and then call
you out and say you're a piece of [ __ ]
if you're trying to scam us
i've got it i have a pdf here now
our old friend colin campbell who's now
uh at vaynercommerce since i'm excited
nice
uh do we want to reiterate one more time
uh where to upload receipts
upload receipts to garyvee.com book
and do people need gas beef to pay for
the gas fees
yes i don't think we're gonna you will
have to mint it which
i will be very thoughtful to make sure
it's not expensive so i will give
thoughts on that but the anticipation at
this point is you'll have to mint it it
won't be air dropped you'll have to mint
the token which will cost like 30 40 60
80. but i'm gonna i'm gonna maybe do a
side i'll give that some thought i may
i'm saying that there's even a dark
horse chance that i might just air drop
it but we'll figure that out
hold on tell me nothing is sold out but
the website says it
ma if you
come on live
dustin text mom we'll get her on here
because we're getting clarities as we
problem solve against this incredibly
big deal
um
okay
uh
raghav you're ready to read yup
by the way while we're golf is reading
and please share this with everybody
garyvee.com book has all the details i
got a little surprise coming too so
please stand by
i like this story a lot the one that we
started with in the intro
this is really good
years ago i had the most difficult
conversation with the client that i've
ever had to have in the course
it was with the top executive years ago
i had oh hold on hold on what's up i'm
sorry i'm sorry we're back having the
course here
it was with the top executive years ago
i think
[Music]
i muted her
okay i think she had the youtube open
that's why yeah
i might have youtube open behind it maha
can you turn that off real quick so we
can get you in regard we'll come back to
you up this is clearly the ragav
interruption show um
the ris is in full speed
yes you've got some you got some
information i'll show you
just to give everyone kind of updates on
links and what they're trying to do so
this is pre-order so you shouldn't be
getting sold out links i know somebody
just paying me target so we're checking
on target but for amazon you should be
fine amazon us but it was on uk amazon
us what they said is that the algorithm
is picking up a lot of traffic coming
into the site so it's getting a little
wonky so people should just kind of shut
out shut down come back in and refresh
and they are um they're aware of all the
traffic and excitement that you guys are
creating for them so they're just
working on all that right now um amazon
mexico has an algorithm thing that
doesn't allow to order more than one
book but they're checking on that so we
have 24 hours don't give up on amazon if
you're in mexico please wait a little
trick if you want a vpn you can get onto
the u.s site so just letting you guys in
on a little way to get around any of the
international stuff um try that as well
and put it into the situation in india
as well
jeff
hey brother it's gary
hey jeff listen
we're we're breaking amazon i need your
help
can you um he's calling
no i know everything's everything's good
brother yeah i know
yeah the other thing just while gary the
nft is crazy but jeff i need your help
you have to upload your receipts within
24 hours so if you take a screenshot of
your receipt or you get an email with
your receipt
you should upload that into the link and
you need to do that within 24 hours and
we got some questions about ebooks
ebooks don't count because you can't go
in and purchase 12 on the software for
your account so please make sure that
you upload your receipt onto the link
there's an airtable link where you guys
can upload that and if you have any
questions we're here to answer them but
we want to make sure that you guys all
know that if you cannot access it for
your international market for whatever
reason try a vpn and see if that gets
you through
what else can i answer for everybody
did jeff bezos uh answer you gary
i didn't call jeff bezos i don't know
jeff bezos i was just having fun with
everybody wanted you know
okay wait is that a hotline yes gee uh
24 hours to upload their receipts um for
a couple of the markets that are having
issues just as there's a lot of traffic
but try vpn if that doesn't work for you
if you're an international marketing
available okay cool thank you maha for
god
years ago i had the most difficult
conversation with the client that i've
ever had to have in the course of my
career
it was with the top executive from one
of the biggest brands we were working
with at vaynermedia a contemporary
creative and media agency where i'm a
ceo
the executive called me and asked if we
could meet face-to-face in midtown
manhattan
that day an entry-level employee at my
company had accidentally posted a tweet
from the client's twitter account
thinking she was logged into her
personal account it was a very negative
tweet about another agency that
vaynermedia was working with to support
the brand to the world it looked like
the brand had made a negative comment
about the other agency
it was hold on one second
yep
tons of questions coming through i'm
getting antsy i just really need
everybody's help on the common questions
that have been asked and then katie and
seth if you guys can step in and just be
in one of those streams and respond um
keep going my friend
it was a it was a very quick meeting
the executive told me she expected this
to not happen again and asked me to put
the proper protocols and systems in
place to ensure that then she said to me
the only way our company sees that we
can go forward working together is if
you fire the person who posted that
tweet
it took me about a hundredth of a second
to think it through i said to her i
can't do that i had to be able to run my
own business and make my own decisions
about my employees that executive had
every ability to fire us if that's what
if that's what she felt was necessary
but it had to be my decision what the
ramifications of that tweet would be
she was surprised the brand represented
about 30 percent of our total revenue at
the time
i was mentally prepared for them to fire
us but at the time i knew that we had
just enough profit or just enough new
business coming in that we could afford
a year with no profit i also had enough
saved up that if we lost money that year
i was willing to help bridge the gap if
needed if we could weather that storm it
would be a clear indicator to our
employees on what we really value
uh this conversation was one of those
interesting moments when you have to
decide what you're going to stand for we
scheduled the call the next day and i
stood my ground luckily the client
didn't fire us
i remember that super vividly
it was super hard
but i never want
a client to dictate what i'm about me
and my employees relationship is more
important to me than me and my
clients and that
was a very big moment in vayner history
and i also had a company-wide meeting
because we wanted to make sure people
understood how
much they had to be careful
um
but that was a big big deal and i'm glad
that i agree with you i'm glad that we
get to start the book with that
yeah um
seth katie can you guys take the mic and
give well i try to get this instagram
live um proper can you tell everybody
what's been going on
yep
gary will you be narrating
your audio book
like every other book i've ever done i
will be doing it yes
um i really really really need some help
from everybody in the community please
if you're watching right now
um
if you're watching right now please if
you're in the comment section on youtube
twitch
uh
periscope instagram
linkedin please push everybody any
question i need like 15 if i could get
15 people in every community to just
push everybody to garyvee.com that'd be
huge and everybody on instagram
if you can get everybody to
know that it's a much better experience
on youtube than it is on instagram
uh what we're doing today is launching
my book that comes out november 16th
pre-order sales
uh the book is called 12 and a half
leveraging the emotional ingredients
necessary for business success i'm
incredibly excited about it
and if you submit on garyvee.com
book your receipt of 12 books or more 12
24 36 48 480. i'm going to do a very
special surprise for all of you that
missed out on be friends i'm going to be
doing a special airdrop
to everybody who has an account that
verified that they bought books
for you to get access to a very special
gift that i plan on being a very good
thing for your 360 dollar investment
which i think will go down in price
three hundred dollars which will go down
in price with the way the algorithms
work we're aware of india we're aware of
the uk we're aware of barnes and noble i
one more time to repeat to everybody
there is a little wink wink that if you
buy 12 on barnes and noble that's a good
idea
and uh and i want to remind everybody
that you can't mint a [ __ ] nft for
300 bucks so getting 12 books
is a good idea
uh what else katie seth dustin or we can
start bringing some people in and we can
do some q a dust if you want to do that
um seems like barnes and nobles is
working well now i'm getting that update
what uh what else are we feeling
yeah q a people
yeah i'd love to get in more into the
book the book is a book for everybody
we're about one more time on the
scenario of the employee because this is
not just for ceos
and upper management i want regard to
read the book is very structured on my
thesis and then i go into scenarios and
some work lessons oh god this book is
gonna [ __ ] slay i know that cause
hollis told me
um
but anyway go ahead
we're aware of india
we're gonna do something for india go
ahead the scenario uh yeah the one with
the employee
the budget cut right the yes
you've been working at a company for
several years people around you will
appreciate your work but you still feel
that you're underpaid you know that the
company is having budget cuts but you
don't want to be insensitive but you
also feel like you deserve more money
given the value you bring what would you
do
well one thing as i'm talking to my
discord right now i'm seeing numbers in
my discord they'll mint eight tokens of
a new project
[Music]
for more than 300 bucks a piece
from somebody they don't know and yet
i'm seeing some replies with 12 and 24
which means they're only gonna get one
or two like please my friends so many of
you underestimated with me with v
friends and it went crazy
and people made 2046 the discord i'm
reading all of you jamie jay like i'm
reading all of you like you're making a
mistake please don't make the same
mistake twice i see a lot of mistakes
and for everybody's asking right now yes
you can if you just submitted 24 and you
now are hearing me and want to buy
another 48 you can submit
uh dustin how are you thinking about
getting people in should i ask people to
say
to reply question in their comments
right now on all these platforms or how
do we get people in
what will work
do you need help
yes so since since uh streamer can only
fit about
five more people
um i just don't know how
like and there's pretty much
why don't we share the url
and if they have a question um
they'll just backlog we'll get five
people in they'll be in the back room
and the first five that get in will
[ __ ] get in
alrighty i mean i think that's right
yeah do you want your own discord it's
just uh yeah let's do on discord take
the url here and just share it on
discord if you're in my disc by the way
you need to be in my [ __ ] discord is
it discord.com is it
garyvee.com
yes let's do that for a second before we
do that there's a huge [ __ ] mistake
by so many of you
you have to be in my [ __ ] discord
let's get that url up here and then
let's get every single i need a
commitment for everybody if you're
watching right now i see all of you
i see you ain't you know uh
zachary band i see you monica z i see
all of you i'm gonna put a url up right
here right now dustin's doing it i think
it's garyvee.com
it is i need you to then type it into
the chat you're in on twitch i see you
on twitch i see you on twitter i see you
on
please
please get everybody into our discord
it's a huge mistake that people aren't
like you know it's huge
huge mistake
you got uh one question here uh you said
receipts can be loaded even after 24
hours as long as you buy the book within
24 hours that's right
but we also heard that uh receipts need
to be loaded within 24 hours which one
is right no no
it as long as you buy it within the next
24 hours by 5 pm eastern tomorrow
you will be able and maybe the website
says 4 30 or 4. if sid if you're
listening let's update the blog post to
5 pm because we start a little late
as long as you buy
12 under 20 1200 before
um
before uh
5 pm eastern tomorrow you can upload the
receipt to the form at garyvee.com
book at any time all right there it is
please everybody right now i don't see
enough of these hyperlink garyvee.com
discord in the chat please do that right
now everybody
i think i got blocked on discord
i'm trying to send a link in the general
section and it won't let me now
will you cap the total amount of nfts
that you'll be sending now 24 hours
we're doing it right now
and
you know it's 12 books at a time so
it'll be a drop and then nfc we'll see
how many editions there are
so now
will not cap but i might drop some
easter eggs
barnes noble what
we got five
lovely gentlemen in here now
all dudes
yeah i guess they're the fastest ones in
this case
i'm going to bring
adrian first okay
adrian what's good
hey garyvee
how are you
i'm good i'm from malaysia it's 5am
right now i got up at 4 3 am just to buy
the bookman thank you brother just for
my own education where did you buy the
books from in malaysia amazon malaysia
amaz amazon malaysia and they will ship
it to us and i tried to buy it from
bands i know what they don't ship to
malaysia so i have to use a forwarder or
something like that
there's a respect yeah do you have a
question anything i can answer
uh
well i wasn't prepared i'm i'm just i'm
just uh i'm guessing that you're gonna
give a nnft for the book right that's
what you have been yelling about like an
author
can use an nft
as part of their book so i'm guessing
that i i don't know if you're gonna
review anything about that
i'm going to make sure that what i drop
all of you
is going to be much better than the 12
books per
that you put in like i always do
99 of the people here thought the nfts
were too expensive it was too silly
adrian they didn't understand that i
will die
i will die
let's say nice and slow i will die
before i ask somebody for something like
money
i think um
with the amount of people trying to join
it's like
crashing up yeah got it that was a bad
idea
if you're watching on discord please
don't try to join anymore
um let me kick some sorry i'm gonna have
to kick some of you people out
everything's crashing we're just
crashing yeah i think we're just messing
up everything
am i still here yeah you're still here
yeah
so yeah i'm [ __ ]
well i gotta i'm gonna try to keep my
good idea was a bad idea
um sorry if i'm freaking out
right now while everybody well
everybody's doing this can you
just keep reading the comments if you
can see them just ask me questions that
makes sense
oh by the way i don't know i don't know
the rating of my book on amazon that's a
good one
i need to can somebody leave a comment
of that in the comments where we're
ranked right now overall in books go
ahead katie
um does the nft have the same perks as v
friends
no
no you're not buying [ __ ] 12 books
and getting the v con
um because it's a pre-order you can
cancel it how do you verify we bought it
um i'm gonna i'm gonna do the
verification after they've all been
shipped so i'm not gonna drop it on the
16th i'm gonna drop it after
do we have a deadline for when we will
respond back to all the people who sent
their receipts in
i'd like to think we'll have it by
october 1st
you good
you're sad
i see yeah seth's here there will be an
or there will be an audio version
darrell
davis daily thank you for your 120s
receipts are only valid if they were
bought
today
in the next 24 hours
if you buy another 12 upload it again as
if it's the first time you're doing it i
see a lot of people coming back
people are asking that they came in late
please everybody click them to
garyvee.com i will recap before we're
out of here
how do we join the discord
discord right here garyvee.com discord
everybody who's watching right now
please
link
hyperlink garyvee.discord in the
whatever channel you're in
zero just got another 24. two shout outs
for zero
people asking how many books they need
to buy in order to be eligible
12 books because the book is called 12
and a half a receipt with 12 books all
the information
is in garyvee.com but for every 12 books
you buy 12 24 36 48 72
you know 720 for every 12 you will be
airdropped
a surprise
i entered 1 128 books and now the order
is on hold most likely it will be
resolved on monday is that too late what
if they reject the order
no i'll i'll
upload your receipts if i see that you
bought it well
if somebody buys 1200 books
next week we'll honor that so like
that's good we'll figure that out
um
katie can you talk to sid and the team
raga or god
is there we go for god if can we create
an email address right now i know sid's
in the background a lot of people
background should we put on the blog
post at garyvee.com uh dustin i think
everybody went to the discord now let's
switch it back to garyvee.com with all
the details but you should be part of my
discord if you're not it's a huge
mistake
um
can five people in each channel please
take over the garyvee.com discord
responsibility and just keep sharing it
join the discord um
maybe we should add an email like
book book help at
vaynermedia.com or something like can
you work on that right now yeah yeah
we'll get it done
don't we have an email
from it's
i don't think it's set up yet
sorry there's a lawn mower
no worries
any surprises if we get a hundred plus
books no but here's a surprise when i
[ __ ] dominate with my surprise i'm
giving you having ten of them is better
than one
ten michael jordan rookie cards are
better than one
okay we have one that's set up
okay it's there uh
you put in the blog post if you have any
questions garyvee.com book
garyvee.com
garyvee.com
i'm aware about india being sold out we
will figure that out
any country that is sold out and you
weren't able to get
you know
you'll be able to adjust but
what maha said earlier is all the
algorithms are updating and over the
next 24 hours you should have a shot
and this is being
recorded
on youtube right so tomorrow morning
when i wake up team i can just like
share this url to everybody and they can
learn everything and they can go to it
is that correct
yeah it should stay up honest dustin is
a different stream now no the youtube
video will stay live same screen yeah
there's also five guests
still if you want to bring it yeah i'll
take one okay
i'm gonna bring on darius
darius it's good
hey what's going on garyvee what's good
fam where are you from
originally from buffalo new york
that's what's up are you a bills fan
yeah i appreciate the bills for sure
damn do i have to kick him out no i'm
not keeping him i like i like his butt
just kidding there's what's good what
can i answer for you
you know what i have like 27 questions
but um
one thing first and foremost i just want
to say shout out to you guys and your
team
i missed out on v friends and um
to be honest i was like screw it today
i'm just taking the leap i'm not even
going to play around with it um thank
you my heart's beating outside of my
chest right now i can't talk to you but
um
but yeah man one of my questions was um
i work in the agency space i run
branding for an agency as well
but when you're talking about
where agencies are going
and you're
you're someone who sees the future is
really kind of outside of the standard
agency model yes
any advice on how to align yourself with
those who really get that because
sometimes that's a losing battle when
you're kicking against
i think what you should do is you should
email me at gary vaynermedia.com and
where are you at now you said originally
from buffalo yeah i'm in fort collins
colorado right now
maybe what you should do is move to new
york or l.a and work at vayner because
then you're just part of it
you know what i wish i could but i
unless you got room for a house of uh
11.
but you know what bro straight talk with
all the virtual [ __ ] now things are
getting crazy right we're not sure we
need people to move either i by the way
two things one you join the party like
i'm trying to recruit you right now and
my emails open
two
you never waiver you just stay
consistent you know
how long have you been following my [ __ ]
uh at least five years
good then you know something very real i
don't [ __ ] deviate i'm [ __ ] on the
same [ __ ] i say it different ways i may
say it on new platforms
i might have different slang but i'm
[ __ ] saying the same [ __ ] and you got
to do the same thing
is there any so is there any hope for
the agency that doesn't really get it
oh yes because as you know clients don't
get it either so it's a slow burn
so like even in your career you're a
young man over the next 10 years it's
not like they they're going to go out of
business
but they're going to continue to lose to
me
and the people that i'm inspiring to
start the new vaynermedias
roger that roger got it and it's crazy
even asking this question because i'm
like somebody in my company might see
this
and uh and truth be told i actually have
a i've gotten a chance to know duveen a
little bit and he's just legit yeah and
um
yeah so everything you guys are doing i
appreciate it um
but yeah i'm just yeah honestly back to
your point like if somebody from your
company's watching this right now they
need to call you in the office not to
scare you they need to call you in the
office and say yo bring that energy to
us
that's real that's what's real let me
know if i can help you watch that
appreciate it guys see ya
let's keep it going let's get one more
in here and then
we'll get ready to read a page from the
book just something random and
and
seth katie get ready for some core
questions and i'll do a recap who do we
have here
you're you're on mute
and everybody who's watching right now
please be the leader in your chat
course so far i see you in discord cody
williams i see you on youtube savannah
like please please please please please
send everybody to the url here
garyvee.com book and please educate
everybody what to do shiv what's good
still on you
yes ryan you just ordered 12 more you
can team you could submit five times
like you might wake up tomorrow morning
be like what the [ __ ] am i doing for 300
bucks i can get another [ __ ] drop
[ __ ] i'm buying another you can
submit it tomorrow too so
should be good
[ __ ] let's go to somebody else and see
if you and ship can figure out behind
the scenes sorry chef we don't have
audio
mind blown this is amazing where are you
from
uh originally georgia living uh grew up
in vegas
did my schooling out in rhode island and
now i live in phoenix i love it it's a
pleasure
wow pleasure pleasure's all mine we do
not need to be friend for everything
we're doing today just saw that question
four times go ahead sami although we all
wish we did
yes
well let's talk about that let's talk
about that please how long have you been
following me
at least five or six years it seems like
forever was it was it financial or you
didn't understand what entities were
like why why did you not buy a befriend
100 completely financial i
actually i finally got the follow from
you for posting messages i was sending
to everybody saying hey
you know let's get on this get on this i
had one boy that was sitting on like 33
heath and i said hey like
you need to pick this up and he didn't
and he
you know what i'm saying like everybody
missed it my dad the family everybody
didn't understand it
and who's and who's come back to you the
last month and be like [ __ ] how'd you
know
yeah at least three or four of them my
boy yeah my boy amir for sure like the
one that was holding all that heat he
bought in in like 2015 you know so he
and the friends are up sixteen hundred
percent minimum it's just it's
unbelievable
we kick ourselves every day for not
being able to pick them up and i just my
dad you know are you in on me
oh yeah i already got 120 i have 132 120
on barnes and noble and then another 12
off amazon just because i don't know
what you're going to do but i know it's
going to be worthwhile like i couldn't
miss it again what are you what are you
going to do with 132 books have you
thought about it yet um giving away my
closest to my inner circle first check
check check check i can hear this
oh my god i don't even
where to even go big shout out to vlad
papa fisky who about 240 in sydney thank
you you got any random question or any
statement or any i want for everybody
who's coming on maybe a story of a piece
of content that changed the game or a
question whichever works
oh my god
i don't know no worries honestly i do
want to i do want to talk this is
amazing you want to take a screenshot
like this is amazing just i'm happy with
it bro i'm happy i don't need a question
i answer questions all day
what about what about this i got a good
question for you uh i do want to say uh
congratulations to dustin though i've
been following justin for a minute and i
know he just got married not too long
ago yeah he [ __ ] us all up he just
like literally like posted on instagram
didn't tell us [ __ ] he's like uh oh you
weren't even invited that's brutal no
dude we didn't even [ __ ] know we were
all like what the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yo let me ask you a question what about
the first time you saw me years ago
cynical like is this guy full of [ __ ]
and then a few minutes later or all in
early sure no it wasn't all in early
i get it i get it i think i've gone in
waves right like
right it's hard you know you know what i
you know what i've realized about myself
i'm gonna say the macro thing like the
game
the same [ __ ] forever the micro thing
tik tok nfts facebook right like my
micro game is [ __ ] best in class
right my macro game is best in class too
because i'm not going to say different
[ __ ] it's the [ __ ] truth
yeah
it's unreal so i do so i'm building a
business a consumer good business hold
on one second i apologize everyone's
asking what dust did dustin could please
share on your screen the beautiful photo
of you getting married
um
just take your phone
katie you want to pull up his instagram
post and put on the screen or something
keep going
so best way to build uh brand awareness
the number one way to build brand
awareness is to arbitrage new attention
tick tock drop in nft
podcast like it's all that i all i talk
about is brilliant
oh absolutely yeah so like by being
first and going hard on the thing that's
popping and by the way
all you have to do is keep listening to
me but when i say [ __ ] do it instead of
not do it like for example someone as
bought in as you next time around
sell [ __ ] in your house
i couldn't get rid of i couldn't move it
i think i even offered it to you i have
like a new york yankee signed world
series ball and stuff and i think i said
it to you via text message just trying
to get get it to offload it i have that
i real quick
i was trying to sell out there it is
thank you brother real quick everybody
who's here
please please share garyvee.com
and your thoughts
on twitter there's a lot going on on
twitter my brother just told me but i
need more people to give explanations
like just tweet if you want to know
what's going on here's a link hashtag
nft because a lot of people are asking
thank you everyone
um bro it's so good to have you on thank
you for your vibes
appreciate you i hope i see you in
person soon one day for sure i know
you're you're in arizona
yes sir you know
depending on what i do with book you
know changing hands in arizona is one of
the places i normally do a book signing
okay awesome so keep it in mind we'll
let you know all right bet thank you so
much
let's keep this going who's this oh
shit's back it's just now i can hear you
bro how are you perfect great great oh
my god oh my god i just can't believe
i'm here i just want to tell you really
quick like i found you when i came to
poland so basically i'm from india i
came to poland in 2017 to study over
here and that's when i found you on
facebook your first video you said [ __ ]
[ __ ] that that's what i got in and
i'm like whoa then i i dug into you and
you came to warsaw poland in 2018 and
so [ __ ] expensive and do you know
what i did
i'm gonna say that
i i snuck in
i broke into your event i posted it on
my inside you can check on my insights
right over there it's in my post and i
literally on the next day i texted each
and everyone on the team garyvee or to
dustin to zayn to see everybody that
i've broken your event
it like it was too expensive bro it was
like seven i get it
you know
they're not my events so i never really
know what the prices are i just show up
you know so i'm glad you were there how
are you
i'm so good and and the unluckiest part
is like i even broke into the vip part
where they were getting selfies with you
when they when they were going i
literally took the video and this is my
luck i'm taking the selfie video because
i didn't want to take a risk off that
bad selfie i'm just taking the video
selfie and just when you and me are
going coming into one frame my battery
died and that clip is on my insta wow
you're now after like four years the
[ __ ] i can't believe it i'm literally
shaking it's like it's really good to
see you
so
real quick i apologize people are asking
if the books have to be bought on the
platforms on the garyvee.com book they
don't actually if you buy 12 books from
somewhere else upload that receipt we'll
see it go ahead my friend
yeah
i said um
i never have this nervousness issue
because i i'm also stage host i host
many events but [ __ ] okay um i have to
ask you this thing because i recently
graduated uh from university and
basically i didn't plan to come poland i
applied for states but i got rejected on
student visa so then i came to europe to
study bachelor's but now i'm in the kind
of place that i want to take a one
semester break and i'm figuring out my
life you know because i'm more into
marketing because of you all thanks to
you because you were all over south of
venice so i tasted many things back in
india i was zero i've never been on a
stage and never been in front of 50
people or more
like
it's you and this new place so i had to
ask you that if i find a way to come to
states can i work at uh vendor media can
i work at team garyvee
you know the reality is is i'm not
against it
your tenacity is incredible your energy
is cr incredible why don't you why don't
you link up with one of the four here
maybe dustin or whoever like i don't
know how the back room works baby katie
i don't know how that works i'm
incredibly willing to give you a reel at
bat
move you to the top of the line and see
what you got
yeah because because honestly like i
applied for student visa three times i
got rejected all three times that's why
i came to europe and now i'm just gonna
find a way to come to states and i
really want that's my dream i want to
work at team garyvee thank you my friend
listen i take that seriously and we'll
take a look at it i'll let you know
thank you brother thank you thanks all
right let's keep it going real quick
recap oh actually ragav let's go to you
let's get back into the context of the
book i believe
please a quick update from maha for
target us the only solution
is to tell customers that they can still
take advantage of the offer by ordering
from an alternate alternate us retailer
aka amazon barnes noble books a million
etc target does not have good technology
infrastructure for pre-orders
for uk and india
um she's in check with her sales team
and from mexico
unfortunately amazon decides to limit
order quantity
no worries yeah that's it no worries big
shout out to terrible who bought 60
books five surprises coming your way
uh ragav is now going to read um an
excerpt from the book that i'm
incredible you know we're very excited
because the nft thing
the excitement late summer
but
at the end of the day the reason this is
all happening is because i want to get
this book into as many hands as possible
so i'm trying to incentivize all of you
to buy 360 books
get get 30 of these incredible special
things i'm doing
win with that but then have 360 books
and be like [ __ ] what do i do with this
go to your local school donate
you know give them out for free
like many things me many many things but
i just this is such a cool thing about
the blockchain
and controlling the entire ecosystem i
don't know i'm just very excited i'm
very excited and i love all of you and
i'm i really think the book is special
if the book
wasn't special i'd probably
be on my merry way and just do what i
did with crushing it which was special
but not very special meaning
i would just be a new york times
best-selling author number one new york
times
by just having a big enough audience but
i wanted to get this book to the world i
want this everywhere i want to send
every coat by the way i want to get
every coach in the world reading this
book i want to get every coach every
athletic team every startup every
corporation they all need it
give us a little bit about it rugoff
oh you're a mute
okay
i'll read a little part from the
conclusion like a little section from
that please
when you develop these 12 and a half
ingredients to your maximum potential
working from nine to five might even be
too many hours in the day
seriously
as you develop kind candor gratitude
self-awareness accountability optimism
empathy kindness tenacity curiosity
patience conviction humility and
ambition you begin to work with minimal
friction your colleagues begin to feel
safe happy and calm around you speeding
up execution
when these ingredients are instilled
properly throughout an organization team
members won't have to spend 30 minutes
in a seven minute meeting they won't
need they won't feel the need to invite
eight extra people because of
insecurities and politics i interrupt
you i apologize yep somebody just wrote
gary you look very tired three things
one probably true i'm up three to three
a.m looking for 2018
2019 nft projects two
i am from eastern europe and bags under
my eye and wrinkle that was there from
the get three
grays come in and you know this is it
guys
i'm not here because i'm [ __ ]
strikingly handsome this isn't a [ __ ]
instagram model life this is [ __ ]
humanity and brains
so
all the comments on my like dude i'm
[ __ ] 45 like i'm not [ __ ] dustin
who [ __ ] looks 19 when he's 39 or
something
like this is where i'm at but like you
know i have a funny i have a funny
[ __ ] feeling
that everybody here is not buying books
because i'm [ __ ] a heartthrob
and to give you a little more extra
credit you'll still outwork them even
though you're tired
yeah by the way like after all these
books are sold i'm gonna get a [ __ ]
afro implant [ __ ] look fresh
just saying no listen i think a huge
trend is
male
hair implants and i'm gonna get a
[ __ ] huge afro and [ __ ] flex on
all you [ __ ] all right keep going
those who need to be in a meeting can be
there and others can focus on their
tasks projects and they can move faster
that was a passage like it was cool that
we talked about like made the connection
between developing these traits and
emotional efficiency
all right keep going
um
give me something else katie
seth yep yep we also have three other
guests still just so you know fine give
me a guest
i just want to say one thing if you
don't buy an extra 12 right now you're
[ __ ] up
do you understand what [ __ ] up is
you're gonna regret the [ __ ] out of it
all of you 99 percent of you regret the
[ __ ] out of the friends i literally
[ __ ] sat there and said what the [ __ ]
am i gonna do about this then i said
[ __ ] it
i want this read by everybody i'm gonna
[ __ ] trick the world into having it
because i'm gonna have people that are
gonna figure out that they [ __ ] up on
may 12th
so they're going to get it and by 360.
people are literally in my discord who
know everything about nft and i'm
looking at these cockamanian small
numbers of like 12 and then next week
they're gonna mint
30 [ __ ]
ambitious ant
society [ __ ] nfts that are gonna go
to [ __ ] zero
and yet they could have had what i've
got for them november [ __ ] man i'm
pissed
aka happy
give me somebody
oh wow hey can you hear me
i can't hear you my friend
oh hello well uh my name is yasin hold
on one second i'm sorry my friend
william ac says you have to admit this
method is a bit scary i'm fascinated by
people
how is this scammy i want you to buy 12
books that are [ __ ] epic for 300 i'm
gonna airdrop you something that's gonna
be worth more on the secondary this is
where [ __ ] people are [ __ ]
confused
well you may see
[ __ ] go ahead my man
uh awesome i'm a little bit nervous i
have to admit don't be my friend
so as i mentioned i live in germany and
i was born here so excuse me if my
english isn't on point your english is
so [ __ ] good compared to my german as
somebody who failed german one twice in
high school proof
is in my instagram report card i think
your english is amazing my man thank you
i really appreciate it um
i'm one of the um admins or mods of the
german refrain community so we kind of
built our own little discord and i
should say hello from all of them please
please
so hello from everyone who's in the
german reference community to you and to
your team
um i have a question and i was wondering
what role i made notes because i tend to
forget my questions
um
what role does kindness play in the book
and
how highly do you value kindness in your
life well god
i think you're just such an interesting
person for this because i say this stuff
over and over and i think sometimes a
different voice helps you went into this
cocoon with me during covid
did you hear the question because i saw
you were paying attention you want to
hear it was that again kindness how does
how does that
should i repeat it yes um what role does
kindness play in the book and how highly
do you value it in your life
[Music]
yeah there's a story in the book about
how somebody stole
a lot of money from gary at one point
they're like uh somebody someone who
used to work at a lot
yes still like a lie i was like
six and six figures oh like
250k or something
more than that yeah um and you'll see
like the reaction it was very much like
by the way clip uh preview my reaction
was very different than my dad's
yeah um that was cool how do you answer
it like from what you've like you've
been really big what do you think
i think in the book writing process it's
i mean
kindness i think is like empathy like
the way you described it was like
empathy but applied in action
so
it was like
the way that gary used it a lot in the
book was when people took advantage in
the different situations
like
stealing money or like
not giving credit or like
um
like making pretend that something
didn't happen when it did things like
that is like when
gary reacted with kindness in a lot of
these scenarios that's what i noticed
yeah it's it's funny i actually think
kindness is the ultimate
superpower
i think it's hard for people i think
kindness is hard for people kindness
comes from a place where you're already
good
the reason kindness is hard for people
is most people aren't good
the reason i'm so kind is i don't need
anything
i'm already good it's all over i'm
searching for nothing i need nothing
from anybody from the world zero i'm
good i'm like [ __ ] good
so
good
excuse me i didn't want to cut you off
no please i like cutting off and i like
what i'm cut off i really appreciate
that answer um and i also wanted to add
that i've been following your content
for
eight years or close to eight years
and i was always kind of imagining this
day would come
so i'm really excited i really
appreciate your time um i also have one
more short question if you don't mind i
do let me jam a little bit more on
kindness for a second and then please do
and i love your demeanor
no no nothing to be sorry about i really
want to change
the way the business world works i've
decided somewhere in the last three four
years that i can do anything and i'm
gonna do something good about it and i
think business capitalism
will never go away and i think we're in
this time in the world where people are
trying to figure out if it's good or bad
right
people struggle with that socialism
capitalism i get all this stuff
i believe that i've come along at the
right time and i'm going to work my face
off and say look you can win for
yourself but you can bring up people
with you
zubin
who runs vaynercommerce texts me one of
the greatest compliments to me yesterday
he literally just said i love you or
you're the best or i got actually i'll
[ __ ] find it this is real life now
let me just do real life i don't know if
you're watching right now brother but i
love you you made my day yesterday
to see if i wanted
it's fun because it's [ __ ] real and i
don't think people understand how real
it is and my message is crushing
basically he said you're the best or
thank you that's all or something very
nice i said oh what's that about and he
said
here we go
let's see here we go ready give me two
seconds
wednesday 9 27 pm that's yesterday or
that's two days ago excuse me
you're amazing that is all i replied oh
question mark he goes you get more joy
from others having fun and making money
than yourself that's why i love you
this is a gentleman who sold his company
to me
and was trying to figure out that was
the right move for him that's how
vaynercommerce was born robbie deeks was
somebody i had who i recruited to my
company and then zubin had his own
company and we bought it
that was after him hanging out he sees
how i move
i see something
and i can
take all the money for myself
plasma bears right i discover it the
other night i know it's gonna be big
as an nft i could have bought them all
myself but i want to go very quickly and
tell everybody
to do it right
because i don't need like i do enjoy
other people winning that's what's
happening right now
these books would have sold just fine
so right now
if i can add another question in between
please um
you you just described so many
attributes and traits would you set
kindness as like sort of an umbrella of
all of them
humanity
like the full humanity of it all
kindness is one of them but i think kind
is different than empathetic
right i also think one of my greatest
strengths
is accountability look what dustin's
talking about dustin i want you to do my
tick tocks dustin's trying to do the
best he can
he makes one that puts something out of
context and i get hate for it dustin's
scared i'm saying to myself i'm
accountable i could have trained just
dustin for [ __ ] nine years and then i
could have let him do it accountability
is a form of kindness
is a form of humanity
yes i think i'm the nicest i think i
will go down as one of the most
i think i will be
very much in the top sphere
of most financially successful
entrepreneurs
ratio to how kind they were
whoa
i believe that i could have
i could have been in a very different
place in my life already financially if
kindness wasn't my number one
and then i think people will say wait a
minute look at gary he's alpha he's
aggressive he's a winner
he's you know ambition is one of my
traits
ambition
ambition comes with to what about
tenacity
tenacity doesn't seem like you know when
everybody hears the word tenacious
they don't think like oh you're so sweet
but i do balance with kindness and
humility
i think humility is one of my biggest
superpowers i think most people watching
right now don't think i'm humble they
think i'm egotistical because they're
not listening they just see the energy
that makes a lot of sense
um so
by the way by the way empathy
for everybody who does think i'm a jerk
because they only watch 30 seconds is
why i can navigate if i didn't have
humility and empathy
i would be too hurt by people thinking
i'm not a nice person and then i would
have stopped
absolutely
it it's 12 and a half
got it's a lot of ingredients
ingredients it's like making a meal
ingredients
i got you
so fortunately for me i was able to
get
two v friends um wow just straight from
the auction um so are you like are you
like freaking out with what's actually
what happens yes and i'm one of those
people who
gets hit up um almost on a daily basis
from people in the space who are trying
to buy one of my like one particular um
v friend
because i think it's
pretty sought after
um
but yeah not only which ones which ones
did you get
i don't know like should i should i tell
you don't have to if you feel
uncomfortable but i'm happy to hear
um
i got a decisive duck because
um i'm a very indecisive person and i
wanted to
remind it yeah and i wanted to always
remind myself to be more decisive and
yeah just leaning on my question um my
main viewfriend is the bubblegum kind
warrior
yes are you [ __ ] kidding me
did you get that that wasn't floor
um it was very close to the floor um on
the first day of the auction two of the
other spectacular kind warriors i think
it's the hologram and
um
one other um were sold at close to seven
like just below seven eighth
and i was looking at the bubblegum and i
always wanted to the bubblegum just from
when i saw it
and i was lucky enough that it kept
going down all the way to just below
four ethereum at that time
and i didn't have more money like that's
literally
everything that i had like all my
savings went into the kind warrior
basically and the decisive duck so
what's the what's the what's the floor
on spectaculars right now it was right
now yeah the floor
i believe on the on bubble gums is
around 37 maybe right and kind warrior
is a massive i mean you're probably
looking at a
60
if like if you were willing to sell it
and the market higher than that you've
been offered more right yes what's the
highest offer share share this will help
people
um close to 80.
right so let's say 80
at today's price 250 thousand dollars
that's life-changing it's like it's
[ __ ] amazing
this is why i'm so excited about today
99 of my audience [ __ ] up you didn't
thank you my friend and honestly thank
you thank you for you exactly i'm pumped
this won't be the same thing as be
friends it can't be
uh but it's gonna be very special and
i'm excited that so many people here are
gonna and again it's going to happen
again literally i'm going to be here in
a year and somebody's going to be like
gary i bought 24 books i have no i why
why because you know this you follow
nfts you can you can't you can't mint
a [ __ ] anything for points you can't
this is 200 and it's going to go down
because amazon's going to go down before
it comes out
and i made that mistake i minted several
other projects that went to nothing but
i also minted obviously some someone's
saying they also recommended that they
were right well that's the other
work go ahead for example the dead heads
which didn't blow up but i'm i genuinely
believe in the project and i still
really like it did you buy world of
women
no because i didn't have any helium left
that one world of women
and i think koalas are going to end up
being good for a lot of people that were
in the room yesterday yeah no but i
think
um yeah i'm just going to say
before before i go into into another nft
project yeah of course you got it you
gotta
i i also was wondering um well obviously
i also
bought
your limited edition collection with
the collaboration with staple pigeon
this is also one of their hoodies by the
way i just ordered so many things that
they had because i love their stuff
but obviously i also ordered the books
and one question i had related to the
books if you don't mind me asking please
um in germany we we can't order from uh
barnes and noble um is that gonna be a
crucial aspect or
no it's a very it's a very subtle
it's very subtle i i've got a couple of
options of where i'm going with it and
i'm trying to think through
you know i don't there's so many people
that can't buy for barnes noble so i
don't want them to be hurt so it's not
going to be cru i
i wouldn't say do i think if you're in
germany sweden india
do i think
shipping it to a u.s address if you have
anybody
to get the receipt do i think it's worth
it
maybe probably you know but i don't
think it's i don't think anybody's going
to cry over it and
obviously you're in the discord
what's happening
with series 2 is going to be a big deal
so this is an incredibly important thing
but the life is long i've got this is
what i'm going to do for the rest of my
life building friends so
i wouldn't i really i really appreciate
your your answer and your time and just
from a personal standpoint um just to
wrap things up because i know that
there's also other people who wanted to
talk
um i really really wanted to thank you
for for everything that you do and that
you've done in the past you you really
inspired me to do so many different
things in my life
and
the only reason like i'm self-employed
now i run a small um
marketing agency here in germany
and that's all been pretty much
just inspired from watching your content
so i also wanted to thank you for that
and uh yeah i really really appreciate
it
i'm proud of you my friend i'm so glad
we did this this
warms my heart really nice to see you
thank you very much thanks team
fun stuff katie seth anything to answer
uh just let me know your amazon reading
should update in an hour or two
maha said understood no rhymes a couple
people wanted a couple people want to
make sure that uh even though target is
sold out that their orders are still
valid
yeah of course of course
yeah uh one one other question uh some
people are experiencing that they
when they place the order on amazon uh
the receipt does not have a timestamp or
date stamp on it
that's fine obviously if they send it in
on the
garyvee.com book now it's gonna be hard
for us to debate that they didn't do it
now
anything else
i'm late why are we buying so many books
good let's recap hi everybody we're
recapping
this book is coming out november 16th it
is called 12 and a half leveraging the
emotional ingredients necessary for
business success i'm incredibly proud of
it uh by the way instagram best viewing
experience on youtube or other platforms
i'm sorry but i love all of you really
um
i'm doing a launch plan today
if you buy 12 books or more in
increments of 12
hence 12 and a half um and send the
receipt to garyvee.com book
i am doing a surprise drop an airdrop
and pretty much figured out that it will
be a unique special nft uh
the week right after that for everybody
maybe on that day maybe a couple days
later i'll see how it all works but
somewhere before december 1st you will
be dropped something if you go to
garyvee.com book you will be able to
fill out the form and attach your
receipt if you're buying right now you
have 24 hours to buy and take advantage
of this special
uh amazon is global so i see a lot of
people where for morocco and others like
go to your amazon locally
upload
um many of you 99 99 percent of you
missed on be friends i don't want you to
miss on this if you've been following
what's going on in the
nft world
300 which is about the average of buying
12 of these is
nothing for one single nft from [ __ ]
projects let alone what i'm doing so
a lot of people in here can give you
their stories please everybody in every
channel share your stories but there's a
real [ __ ] shot with this
it's a big [ __ ] deal i'm looking to
over deliver and don't forget nfts have
smart contracts
so you can do things so it's not just a
collectible
don't ever forget that
uh common questions i've been seeing it
as people are starting to put their
[ __ ]
understanding they're like wait a minute
um can i buy more because i only bought
36 couple hours ago yes you can you can
keep uploading
um
and so uh here we go
maha has a url
for the uk
maha i know you texted me but i can't
see it
uh can you please share in here and
maybe you can come on screen for a
second and talk about where you're
pushing uk people
and then maybe people can share that url
in here
uh let's
have katie and seth keep asking
questions while we're for maha maybe we
can't have a little bit of a hard time
getting in because we have people
respect it's too uh it's anybody
struggling with amazon uk would suggest
buying from waterstones
waterstones yep i know it well i've done
some signings there so cool so that's
what's going on a real opportunity where
the 12 might be
books you buy may return in a really
good way to what you get and then you
can share some stuff
so no updates on india yet um india will
probably have to be something we do
another offer for
given the sold out situation we'll
figure that out
um gas on the airdrop is a great
question if you're nerdy i'm gonna try
to time it
i may go off chain
it may not be on main net to lower the
gas piece i'm going to figure that out i
got a couple months here to figure that
out
um let's keep it going let's get a guest
in here
people are saying what the [ __ ] is water
stones people please share the
waterstones url
if you know it if we can put up the
waterstones url up here
um
waterstones is a very major uk book
signer who do we have jc yeah
jc what's good
you're on new jc
okay you guys here yep we can hear you
now bro
okay awesome man whoa i'm excited to be
here
from the netherlands myself very nice
yeah man so um one question i had was uh
i'm uh
probably gonna quit school my college
university in a couple of days uh
till the 31st of august to
decide
um
what would your advice be to me
as someone who has just been
crazy involved in this nft game
first you should know that we're in the
bullish run so may it you know these
crazy numbers are not going to last
forever a lot of shit's gonna crash
but you're a young man so i would take
profits off the table if you have
something you have some profits
yeah definitely good so i think one
thing you have to balance is when is
this crazy run gonna stop
and so
you may want to create like if you get
crazy and it goes really well take some
profits and put it into a bank
they'll give you less to play with which
is bad but when it crashes you'll have
six months on your feet so that you
don't have to panic too many people will
play too far
it'll crash
and then they're gonna have to go get a
job again
all right or go back to school you
understand so find a balance and you'll
regret it because you're gonna be like
[ __ ] why did i listen to gary that 5000
bucks i could have put into but
when it crashes you'll love me
that's my number one piece of advice i
appreciate it yeah i've been just saving
up i'm still living in my parents house
you know so it's not really i like
anything yeah i like that you know a lot
of times i say get out of your p like i
love people living at their parents
house as long as they're not making fun
of their parents and taking advantage of
their parents and treating their parents
with the respect they deserve
yeah i know i'm really okay with my
parents uh they do a lot for me for sure
yeah
so um one thing you said was that you
have learned a lot of in your business
from your uh a lot you learned from your
mother right so yes
yeah it's funny this book this book has
a lot more to do with the way my mom
parented me and how i then interpreted
it into business than anything else
okay so what is one thing um like the
most important thing you learned from
your uh father father your dad
my dad what i learned number one
is
honesty matters candor
matters
my and and my dad's work ethic was
unbelievable
unbelievable
he just
[ __ ]
outworked everybody
and so i learned that from him
okay i appreciate it thank you um i was
just uh and tenacity my dad is a
tenacious negotiator my dad's a much
better negotiator than i am
cool
all right and by the way my father also
taught me a lot of things i don't
my dad taught me a lot of things by
showing me things i didn't want to do
you know not not to like [ __ ] on my dad
i love my dad more than breathing i had
the best combo with him today but you
know my dad came from russia
and that was a very tough system
and the way he treated his employees was
something i didn't want to do and i
think that pushed me aggressively and
a lot of the themes here
have to do with the opposite of what my
dad did
interesting yeah
so like the um
yeah the things you saw in russia back
in russia have uh like
puts your mirror to more towards the
capitalism side you would say
capitalism was in my blood i would have
been that in russia i just would have
been put in jail
you know so i just got lucky to be in
america
yeah cheers brother wish you well great
time man take care
by the way everybody who's watching in
america speaking my dad please put it up
dustin we have a crazy september i just
did all the buying winetext.com if you
buy wine on the internet let's give my
dad a shout out here i love him he gets
so happy when people sign up for wine
text if you buy wine on the internet if
you buy wine in america
please please please please sign up for
winetext.com winetext.com make sasha
happy
for everybody who buys from wine tax and
sees the ridiculous deals please share
with everybody how epic it is actually
it's really remarkable anyway let's keep
going uh katie seth uh
anybody who's got something update for
maha uh she's working in india tell
people in the us to go to amazon and
barnes and nobles both are working well
target uh we likely cannot fix right now
but those two are working well in the
u.s work on mexico as well
more people asking how do i get proof of
purchase from amazon um if you go into
your amazon orders you should be able to
screenshot the order uh within that
awesome
uh doing a little surprise thing for aj
real quick if you bought books please
say
on twitter right now hey at garyvee and
how many books if everybody's watching
right now please go to twitter and reply
hey you gotta start with hey cause if
you start with garyvee nobody sees it
hey at garyvee bought 12 books hey
garyvee bought 24 books me and aj do a
little something so
just texting with him it's a lot of fun
uh thank you mahad you're here what's up
uh quick update for our big people our
market in india so i know we're having a
lot of trouble use the uk link for water
stones
one more time so for the mark everyone
in india who's been having a hard time
get through uh to order their books
through that amazon link
use the water storms link for the uk so
it's www.waterstones.com
book slash 12 and a half gary vaynerchuk
let's do this why don't we create
garyvee.com
indiabook
and like create that micro url team and
then we'll place it here so you're
saying watersons in the uk is going to
ship to india yeah they they'll be able
to fulfill the orders from that one and
we want to make sure that everyone in
india who wants the book and be able to
try to order from okay so team can we
make a gary v duck i have the link on
the youtube description just so you know
beautiful so if you're watching on
youtube there's a link let's add that
link
let's create a short url i just did that
uh
that wow justin can you take off the
wine text on the screen yeah
how many should we buy honestly team all
i'm going to say is if you paid
attention to be friends
just don't make the same mistake twice
buy as many as you can
yeah the other last update is amazon is
going to have the ranking on the book so
everyone who's been buying the book
we're going to get the amazon ranking
within the yeah it's every yeah i know
they go every couple hours i get it
it won't be as big as you think it's
like i've always noticed that in moments
like this through the last five bucks
it'll be like at midnight when the
highest ranking comes they said they
need a couple hours yeah exactly
all right
we'll come back faster updates you guys
have any issues with links let us know
and we'll get them answered for you maha
you could keep this open if you want
i'll just take you off screen
okay sounds good that way you don't have
to keep
fighting fighting with other people
we just made that url by the way
garyvee.combook
yeah maybe you uh maybe destiny could do
something with that
work on that uh katie seth
let's just keep reading the comments and
just rattle off questions for me while
dustin does his things
no the books are
good when will you announce what the nft
is
i won't it will be a full surprise
literally one day
i will just say
book people here you go you know and
we're going to email everybody right
because we're capturing emails on the
forum right
so everybody's just going to get an
email it's going to say go here
i'm going to try to keep down the cost
of the gas of minting it
you know but even with the 360 and the
100 like we'll figure it out we'll we'll
work on it between now and then it'll
just be a complete surprise out of
nowhere out of absolutely nowhere
hopefully before december 1st in between
november 16th and
could be on drop day we'll see we'll see
how i feel but and i've got a real
concept for what i'm doing and here's
the big punch line this may make
everybody get another 120 of them
i plan on making that nft matter forever
should i buy 12 bucks yes dustin
yes
remember you know how i've been saying
over and over like don't make the same
mistake i get it sweeter to buy for me
because i'd give you 12 books but i
won't give you the nft
12 books here i come
you
i like how dustin's like wait a minute
he's talking to me
yeah and by the way like dust you have
12 people you could give the book to
yeah definitely yeah i mean by the way
it's also november 16th you want to talk
about something smart first of all
dustin you could just walk into my
office and get me to sign them all
just like you just did your christmas
shopping yeah i need you to send my
sneakers too still you got it happy to
do it
come over come over
okay
all right uh this is up right now
garyvee.com indiabook this is a link to
waterstones uh retailer in the uk
that ships to india you guys are in the
game now
get serious
same for other parts of probably europe
for that matter maha can you confirm
like i see morocco i see a bunch of
other places let me know about this
waterstone thing
okay
dust seth anything else and we'll get
somebody else on screen
people's still wondering how many books
to buy
okay
you buy 12 at a time for every 12 you
buy
you get a surprise gift that i've been
talking about if you buy 24 you'll get
two of them if you buy 36 you've got
three of them actually right now
everybody in one fall swoop don't say
anything but a number how many have you
bought so far just reply with your
numbers ready just your numbers a cop
not got just your numbers
go in the comments just your numbers
not fake numbers 69 200
real numbers
there you go so as you can see people
playing it differently
a lot of 12 some zeros respect totally
understand if you can't afford don't
believe a lot of 24's a lot of 36 120
108.
look what i'm gonna do
is really focus cory i'm sorry you got
zero i love you though thank you so much
for being here totally get one that's
all i could for respect that and i'm
grateful for it and the book is gonna be
well worth the 20 bucks 30 bucks 456
that's a big one
what if they don't have a metamask
wallet yet
you can get one after the fact you're
going to upload
you're going to upload
right now your meta mask but
team correct me from wrong we're going
to email people and say if you don't
have your metamask updated go here right
i'm going to do all that [ __ ] so you got
time
nice smooth faith goons six hundred
[ __ ] people gonna win
will i be i'm gonna do a book signing
get ready now
covent permitting
i will be doing a book signing at wine
library
in the winter
start making your plans we'll try to
give you at least two months of advance
so you can fly out we'll give you hotels
and surrounding areas
i expect lines around the building come
to the mecca the place it all started
i will be doing a book signing at wine
library and it's going to be [ __ ]
huge
it's going to be huge
um so you said will this be as big as
defense i don't think this would be as
big as be friends
i really don't but i do think everybody
who buys 12 books times whatever will be
very happy they did because don't forget
this is 24 hours like there's a lot of
people that didn't see this it's
vacation i do this on purpose friday
night friday evening friday late
afternoon friday summer late summer
think about when i'm doing this
you don't promote [ __ ] now
go talk to a normal business person you
don't [ __ ] do a hardcore launch on
august 27th why did i do that because i
want my hardest core just like i did
with my discord i want my hardest core
to win because
whether i issue 50 000 of these 20 000
of these 90 000 there's still 8 billion
people i'm also going to go all in
forever
all in forever
to make sure that asset is worth way
more than the books you bought
let's go there you go donate the books
and the big key is i'm just trying to
trick all of you to buy as many of these
so you thoughtfully give this i want
every high school coach if you were a
coach of a sports team
at any level
like that guy in ted lasso the guy who
[ __ ] retired and [ __ ] coaches
six-year-old girls
or if you're [ __ ] eric spoelstra eric
i'm sending you one
i want you to buy one for everybody on
your team every coach this is a coaching
book
every hr department every high school
every college every [ __ ] human needs
to read this because we're going to
change the way entrepreneurship is done
which will make the world better kind
good
can we confirm if shiv aviar really
bought 3 468 books shiv send me that
receipt because i actually weirdly
believe you
which is [ __ ] brilliant actually shiv
i hear
i see your i see it and i kind of
weirdly believe it send me your receipt
to gary vaynermedia.com i want to see it
tennis coach from texas el paso about 24
i love that
madame bronco thank you
i love this
i think taiwan has to have amazon no
we're looking for blank yeah
do uh do kindle books count for it so we
have one kindle plus 11 physical
yes but we're really looking for 12
receipts i mean i won't nitpick but like
i'd really prefer you by 12 and just get
the kindle for yourself because that's
how we're kind of really running the
system
confirmation shows 12. it's a lot of man
and women hours if it's 11.
you'll have to upload two receipts but
you can
stacy campbell bought 3
468 books
is that true you see the receipt have
the receipt
okay that's
brilliant i don't know
it's just brilliant
it's [ __ ] smart man
this couldn't work out so well because
then i think about what she's doing how
many people you know if you're a
business person right you lick this
right katie if i'm a business person and
i've been really following me i buy
i buy
720 books and then do a conference where
everybody gets a free book
but then i get all the
like it's [ __ ] brilliant
like if you own a company you should buy
as many as employees you have if you
have a company you could put 48 of these
in your lobby and just give them the
people it's also christmas and hanukkah
and all that time of year like
you can also buy like 48 and just give
them out to people and be nice because
it's a compounding effort it's not like
it's a bottle of wine
like you give this to somebody that's
your doorman
uh your mailman your
50 people like in your town just go to
mailboxes in your
development and just put them in there
it's gonna work for them
i'm really excited about this team i'm
going to be heading off soon because the
jets play a preseason game that i have
to watch in about 45 minutes so i'm
going to be out
this is it like start getting your
questions in like
it's a big deal don't mess up and when
it's over it's over just so you know
when this is over in 24 hours when it
expires it's [ __ ] over
and no you're not gonna hit me up and be
like please no [ __ ] no
um someone asked if you can please
explain the values so they bought real
quick real quick real quick i'm worried
about this jordy says i'm willing to
miss all my savings but will i get
financial return jordy do not do that
i'm way more confident of series 2b
friends which will come out later
i think this will be a win but i can't
guarantee it because i don't know how
many people are buying it but no matter
if everybody bought a billion i still
think i'll be able to create more demand
for it than the supply but i don't think
you should ever bet on not knowing
everything
all your savings you should make a nice
bet because i trust myself but don't go
crazy
no
qq said i bought 84 books in one order
do i upload receipts seven times nope
just one time i assume the forum on
garyvee.com book makes that obvious you
can just upload it because part of the
forum asks you how many groups of 12 did
you buy and you would just write seven
there quick way and then we would be
able to see that confirmation
well it asks how many books they buy so
he should say how many he bought
yeah i mean you guys right 84 i'm sorry
i didn't right right we changed that
right you'll see just go to garyvee.com
to upload your receipt
one more time for everybody like the way
you actually enter is you have to go to
garyvee.com book
fill out the form and put in your
receipt
the value of nf
sorry can someone please explain the
value i bought 60 books so how many nfts
would be dropped
five
you will get five of the thing i'm doing
and then you'll hold them you'll trade
them you'll sell them you'll give that
you'll you'll figure out what you then
you're in control
somebody asking if uh all the entities
are gonna be the same
i think yes
maybe
i'm not sure
we'll see
yes likely
maybe not we'll see
bottom line is everyone's going to win
someone asks um you need to specify it's
an east address not meta mask so can it
be another
non-custodial wallet i think yes
absolutely
anything like anything that
allows me to know it in case we're going
to airdrop but if not you'll get the
email to mint it we're figuring this all
out
kindles do not count ebooks do not count
audiobook does not count 12 receipts of
hard book or softcover on a receipt
if you'd already bought in a kindle and
then 11 we'll count that
if you uploaded both receipts
[Music]
your real name is not required i don't
give a [ __ ] about you and i'm not doing
this for your first party information i
don't even [ __ ] need it we're going
to the blockchain web3 doesn't even
matter anymore
if you don't have a metamask yet or a
non-custodial wallet get one because
you're going to need to get your air
dropped item in there
you do not
you do not get a series 1 v friend
because those are all gone
but you will get something that you'll
be happy about
i'm super excited too cc cooper
do we have somebody in the back let's do
a quick thing
adrian
you're on mute just so you know
oh
hey
hey adrian
uh
i'm
not expecting this uh i'm from sweden
sweden very nice yeah
um
so
i'm looking forward to the chapter about
the employee
and
thank you i love that why is that my
friend
yeah because i i kind of recognize the
situation
i love that actually with with that
motivation thank you for catching that
ragav can you pull up another scenario
and read it to everybody while we've got
my friend here because
i'm i'm so glad you just said that you
just made me very excited i we were real
i was really challenged with how i
wanted to do it
because i really wanted this book to
land and i realized i'm a storyteller so
scenarios would work and they were very
complex scenarios with very complex
answers with stuff that i don't think
people i mean i really believe this
book's going to change a lot of people's
lives which is why i'm doing all this
for god read something for us
here's another scenario here's the yeah
scenario you're 15 years old and you're
making about 1400 a week from trading
sports cards
you're you're a straight a student at
school but your grades are now starting
to slip you're also less interested in
lacrosse even though you're a freshman
on the varsity team position for ivy
league schools your new sports card
addiction is keeping you up late at
night and you would rather spend time
trading rather than studying playing
lacrosse or enjoying casual escapism
like fortnite
what would you do
the reason that one's exciting my friend
is
that's a story that's going to help a
lot of people because there's a lot of
parents that have kids going through
this right now
because all these opportunities that the
new internet and the blockchain give and
there's a lot of youngsters going
through this like these are the kind of
challenges we go through with the
ingredients so i'm excited so thank you
for saying that
were you able to get any books my friend
was sweden did it work
can you hear me my friend
so i i i
84.
oh that's
totally insane
what are you gonna do with the 84 bucks
um
do you hear me yes i hear you a little
delayed but i hear you
so real quick somebody asked to ask
something real quick give me one second
somebody said if there's 50 000 nfts how
would that be worth something yeah i
don't know
because more than 50 000 people are
gonna want it so we're delayed here
yeah
my friend i'm going to say goodbye
because there's something going on with
our audio i love you thank you so much
and good luck and thank you for being
here
let's go to the next one by the way
let's let's let before we go to this
level like um
it's all supply and demand
what if i make those fifty thousand
dollars have access to something that's
worth more than three hundred dollars
you didn't think about that did you
dustin
people don't realize the reason that the
teas are special is they're not just
collectibles they're contracts
what if those
what if those nfts get you a free signed
book every time i do a book the rest of
my life
anyway who's up with us i didn't think
about that it's crazy you didn't think
about it crystal how are you
pretty good i'm a moderator for your
discord thank you thank you for your
efforts you're welcome how you doing hi
everybody from the month doing good um i
did buy some books thank you i went
ahead and bought
i originally was buying 12 and then you
said buy more so i bought 24 more
i've got all my christmas presents
covered so i'm good
i love that and what about chris do you
have a v friend
i actually was gifted a beef friend i
came into this scenario last minute at
the end of april i came in with zero
dollars someone was giving away a free
nft that i flipped for 140 bucks i got
that
and flipped it for a while at 0.06
which was like 140 bucks at the time now
it's worth like 10 000.
and then someone's giving away i want
everybody real quick i really need you
to this is why i want people to hear
this
say that one more time slowly because
nobody knows what a wow is
like let's break it down because i need
people to hear this because a lot of
people watching still haven't gone into
nfd it's a special time with crazy
opportunities that are unlike anything
else i want you to say that nice and
slow one more time please
yes so i came in with no ethereum when's
the first time you heard about nfts was
that by following me or did you hear
about it before yes
from you i heard of a crypto before that
and i had actually gotten some ethereum
through my business at one point in time
but
no nfts at all until
may
keep going and then someone was giving
away a free nft in the community i think
they were doing it so that they could
get them sold and get the residual
income from royalties makes sense so i
snagged one for maybe ten dollars worth
of gas
and so you took ten dollars in gas to
get this nft that people are giving away
for free because if it sells they would
get
and that's how they did the distribution
they didn't have what i have behind me
and then you sold that first free nft
that you got for 140
yes
keep going and i use that to buy a world
of women nft
now why did you know about the world of
women at ft
well you had
posted about it so i was like alright
i'm going to go ahead and try this out
as my first bought nft so i went ahead
and did that
now the reason i asked that crystal to
do that because i want everybody to hear
this one of the things we're doing in my
discord dustin changed the url everybody
who's watching please tag garyvee.com
as you know because you're one of the
mods thank you so much
we're educating and i'm giving insights
free insights in there so you don't have
to own a beef friend
i'm just continually providing value in
there one of them was hey i think this
project world of women's a winner check
it out you saw that you're like wait a
minute i got 140 bucks let me go mint
one of them which means buy it on the
initial release which it's almost like
opening a pack of cards you just
randomly got one keep going
yes and then once that started to go up
i think right now as looking at the
floor it for my version is almost three
ethereum
which is about ten thousand dollars so
you've got something for free because
you've learned about nfts and you
figured out why somebody would give it
away for free you got educated you spent
time
you then took that 140 bucks that in
profit to mint something that you got
from good insights from somebody that
knows the [ __ ] they're doing for free
and you basically turn zero into ten
thousand dollars you could press one
button right now and sell it for ten
thousand and that's a real story that
sounds ridiculous but is really what's
going on correct
correct and i think that is what the
emphasis that i wanted to make is people
do talk in the in your discord about how
the friends are so expensive now because
they they slept on it initially and i'm
trying to emphasize that you can get
into this game even now
with very little you don't have to have
ten thousand well by the way by the way
that's my secret trick right here with
this
people gonna get the best book the best
christmas presents the best hanukkah
presents the best quads and presents or
just can use it for kindness or team
building or strategy or giveaways or
sell their first conference because or
whatever they want they could build a
little house in their apartment i don't
know
but i'm tricking them into getting
something that i'm going to give to them
for gas so it might cost 30 60 90 bucks
we'll see where gas is the london fork
i'll adjust my strategy based on what
the reality the moment is
but then even if it's 50 000 i have
crazy demand
i could sell 50 000 nfts right now in
four minutes
for
500 4 minutes
yeah yeah and then getting a b friend i
mean that in itself's worth what thirty
thousand now
yeah the different thing is nothing
yeah how'd you get the b friend
uh there was a player uh one of your
members in the discord not a mod or
anybody was doing giveaway and i want it
through that
no way so i will be at vikon yeah
is it a core
it is a core it's a common uh catfish or
a compassionate cabbage i love that do
you find yourself compassionate or is it
something you want to work on
i i feel like i am i i constantly am
working i'm the one that creates all the
funny gifts in your discord
so i'm constantly trying to have
compassion for people to prevent them
from falling for scams or something like
that
i love this
yeah
i also wanted to give a moment of
silence to our postco workers for all
these books they're gonna have to
deliver
they've got their system down they're
pretty impressive thank you so much for
being on thank you for all your
contributions in the discord thank you
for that story i hope that i hope that
empowered somebody to put in the hours
of work that you put in
and i don't know if it was three hours
10 hours 15 hours but the return of
hours
for what you've got is absurd there's
not
i live through internet one i live
through social media i know when it's a
land grab of opportunity we are in the
land grab of opportunity
right exactly it won't always be like
this in a year from now not
ever most projects are gonna 99 are
going to fail not
75 which is it's insane
i think people really need to understand
you have to do research you can't use
this as a get rich quick scheme and
that's what everybody thinks it is yeah
yeah like i mean i'm scared to death to
launch my project until i do all the
research on smart contracts because
i don't want to mess it up correct
i love it thanks for being here thanks
that was awesome
katie seth forgot dustin for you guys
what have you learned
you know actually how about this
this is interesting so we're busy we're
rolling uh all of a sudden early january
you're like what the [ __ ] is gary doing
give us your own journeys um like the
first time you heard me say nft
or you saw the pictures of me drawing on
twitter and you thought i'm losing my
mind like give me your own versions
of like what you saw what was going on
with god you might you were in it
because we were working on the [ __ ]
book
yeah that's what tipped me over the edge
because before i was i was kind of
confused about it but
like you were talking about my
cryptocurrency you were talking about
what was like like nfps there's so many
nfp examples throughout the whole book
that that pushed me over the edge
remember when the publisher was like hey
not so many nft examples for the book
i'm like [ __ ] that
yep
dustin your first thoughts when nfts hit
your radar or you saw me doing [ __ ] like
what
um
even though i
100 believe in you because i i really do
i didn't buy anything because i just um
i just you know for financial reasons i
just thought like well but do we
remember the little talk i had with you
about selling your pokemons and maybe
going into nfts
that just felt i guess a little bit more
feasible to me because it's a physical
thing but images just felt like i wasn't
i was like i just didn't understand it
what about now do you do you understand
it a little bit more or still no which
is okay
i mean i understand it
and i'm seeing
not even just you just other people like
i'm always just saying like other people
talking about it so
um
you feel it's coming yeah
seth
it took me a while to really understand
it or to really get a grasp on like
what is possible from it and then it can
also link to something in the physical
world that it's like it's not only just
a jpeg it's not only just a piece of art
but it also can like what what did you
when you when did you first hear it from
me like when was the first time was it a
picture like i feel like the first time
i started it was
i think it was when you started drawing
and posting on twitter and i started
this and did you yeah did you hit up
somebody and be like what the [ __ ]
gary doing yeah and what did they say
losing his mind
it's a combination of that and uh
there's a big project coming this is
kind of what it is
and were you like what the hell
i definitely didn't get it at first same
same thing like what dustin said like i
i trust you and i believe you but
it like it took a while to click
understood
katie
well for the two and a half years i've
been on this team i've never seen you
that excited about something so i
completely trusted you and knew
things were
big here but i didn't start getting into
it until i talked to through gov about
it this week and i'm pissed at myself
for not getting to be friend and all of
that um
so it's something that i'm like
really
gonna do homework on
now because i just know it's huge it's
taken me
like honestly it took me
you were talking about it a lot a lot in
march is when the team really started to
work on it so i
i've heard things i've had to like
listen to content that we've made and
stuff so like i understand it but it
took me a good like month month and a
half to really understand what the hell
nfcs were
because it's new it's new it's like i
was there in 96 when everyone's like
internet that's stupid
right
social media like every single person
and i mean all of them when i was
talking about twitter
was
that stupid who would care what you're
doing
yeah and i i remember you
talking about deadheads you like
messaged our
team thread and was like i really
believe in this and i wanted to do it
and i have like a metamask and but i
just wasn't confident enough that i knew
enough about it to get anything
so
now it's something that i'm really
diving into
i get it i get it i get it i get it it's
good um all right everybody we're
getting close to the end here let's
recap one more time
what you're seeing is let's switch back
to garyvee.com book
um
go check that out it has all the
information
12 and a half my new book if you buy 12
copies
of the book
um and send a receipt in you will get
airdrops something incredibly incredibly
special
in
the winter
and uh after november 16th and
this offer expires tomorrow 5pm eastern
american time
it's as simple as that
thank you for all of you who've been
with me along the way here
the
opportunity is real
please if you want to learn a lot more
because we're about to shut this all
down please go to my discord all of you
should be there you need to learn about
nfts
please do that that's
garyvee.com discord
please do that real big thing
and yes oh you got something
yeah can we can we get one more one more
dude on he's in the back is part of our
crew our internet
hey gary good to see you again bro good
to see you again my friend how are you
fantastic fantastic oh you and i you and
i actually i'm so pumped i bought 12 for
speaking about that about 12 to spread
over here australia
and uh i got some big news for you
what's that
remember last year you and i chat about
on tv yes and you and i predicted
you came to australia and i said i was
going to be ready so yeah i'm part of
team vayne australia
i love you working with amy
yes i'm so proud of you that's amazing
my friend welcome to the team
so i'm glad you're part of vaynermedia
thank you my friend
cheers i'll see you there soon so yeah
all right
i'm gonna close this off team thank you
for all your help dustin
seth katie thank you so much as always
uh
this is gonna be it this is the last
push please please please
please don't miss this tell your friends
this is real garyvee.combook
closes
in you know
22 hours and i'll be it
and then the drop will happen and it
will matter and the same thing happened
to be friends is why did i buy 12 more
why did i buy 24 more why did i buy any
why didn't i tell my friends to buy it
and and the best part is it's all one
big elaborate plan to make sure this
book gets into as many human hands as
possible because i think what we wrote
in here
with the incredible gobs help thank you
my friend
what we wrote here is so [ __ ] crazy
so [ __ ] crazy
um
i'm completely confident that changing
the way business is done changes the
actual world
because business is here to stay
people are selling
rocks from the get it's a human trait
but it can be redefined and it can be
more inclusive kinder smarter thoughtful
strategic long-term not transactional
kind
you can feel better about it every day
and that's what we're on a mission for
so
thank you so much
i love all of you please please pass it
on and please go to the discord one more
time to the discord garyvee.com discord
to continue the conversation
see you thank you enjoy cheers
bye love you see ya bye